Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Wetten, dass wir diese Sendung auf jeden Fall überziehen werden?
Top! Die Wette gilt.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 558 vom, was haben wir heute?
Na, 3. September 2026 und wir sind live auf der Bühne.
Bei der Attention.
Genau. Mit nur ganz wenig technischen Problemen, die bestimmt überhaupt kein Problem sein werden.
Das ist auch bei anderen Sendungen nicht, Tim. Das ist das erste Mal,
dass ich das sehe, dass du mit dem Kram da nicht klarkommst.
Schlimm, oder?
Mich langweilt das. Ich guck mir lieber hier gleich andere Clowns an.
Und Artisten.
Die verrenken sich noch mehr als du.
Ich bin Artist. Guck mal, steht hier drauf?
Nee, da steht Attention drauf.
Ja, steht drauf, aber du hast gesagt, wenn ich so ein Bändchen trage, bin ich Artist.
Ja, aber du hast bisher kein Rad geschlagen.
Ja, aber mal gucken, ich schlage, ich gebe dir gleich Rat.
Ja, wir sind Tim und Linus, wir machen Logbuch Netzpolitik, das ist ein Podcast,
kann man im Internet hören.
Und heute haben wir uns gedacht, erzählen wir mal lustige Geschichten und da
es immer selber nichts einfällt, haben wir uns noch einen Gast eingeladen,
nämlich Stefan Pelser vom Zentrum für politische Schönheit.
Hi. Darf ich dir was sagen?
Wir stellen dich vor.
Stefan ist der Eskalationsbeauftragte des Zentrums für politische Schönheit.
Er ist der Projektleiter vom Adenauer SRP Plus und er ist stolzer Träger des
Bezirksverdienstkreuzes von Friedrichshain-Kreuzberg, nämlich des Silvio-Meyer-Preises 2026.
Und Stefan ist nicht das erste Mal bei uns in der Sendung. Ich fasse das jetzt
schnell zusammen. Wir hatten schon mal eine Sendung, das war die Logbuch Netzpolitik
516. Man darf alles auf dem Dach haben.
Mal schauen, wie diese Sendung sich gehalten hat, wo wir über euer Projekt gesprochen
haben, den Adenauer SRP+.
Das Fahrzeug wurde mit Spenden finanziert auf dem 38. Chaos Communication Congress.
Das war es noch im Bau. Seitdem ist es im Einsatz.
Von innen spannend ausgestattet mit allerlei Faxgeräten und Hängeregistern und
dort drin sind die ganzen Belege für die Verfassungsfeindlichkeit der AfD aber
auch eine AI-Weide mit der man sich über das Wahlprogramm unterhalten kann.
Das ist wirklich, also wenn ihr mal die Gelegenheit habt, den Adenauer zu besichtigen,
das ist wirklich wunderschön, da sind hinten so Zellen drin und bei einer der
letzten, da guckt man dann so rein und dann ist aber auch direkt so der Hinterkopf
von Alice Weidel, die da mit das ist alles sehr,
ein wirklich tolles Fahrzeug im feinsten BRD-Stil der Bonner Republik, würde ich sagen.
Und hatte eine Sirene auf dem Dach inzwischen nicht mehr, ne?
Ne, die haben wir abgebaut.
Warum?
Weil das immer, wir haben, Eskalation ist ja eigentlich was Gutes,
aber es war so, dass quasi Sirene an, Polizei schlägt Scheibe ein,
aber und dann noch, und Menschen spenden uns Geld.
Das war so ein ganz dummer Mechanismus, der war uns aber zu billig.
Also Sirene an, Polizei schlägt Tür ein und 10.000 Euro spenden in einem Rutsch.
Das kann man dreimal machen, aber dann wird es langweilig.
Und das heißt, und dann, ja, also deswegen, die Sirene ist mittlerweile unten,
aber wir haben statt der Sirene ja diese wunderbare PA aufs Dach gebaut dann.
Die ist wie eine Sirene, aber man kann quasi abspielen, was man möchte.
Die ist bekannt geworden im ARD-Sommerkonzert.
Sommerkonzert mit Alice Weide.
Applaus.
Ja.
Und der ist auch ein Anhänger dran manchmal?
Genau, wir haben den Bass-Anhänger dann irgendwann gebaut.
Ist ja auch ein kleiner Bus.
Genau, ein kleiner Bus. So wenig Bass, brauchst einen Bass-Anhänger.
Und ihr Vater mit seit jetzt weit über einem Jahr auf Demonstrationen,
Aber auch, ihr macht die Schulhof-Tour.
Ja, da soll ich was zu sagen, ne? Ja. Genau, also wir machen ja dieses,
das haben wir letztes Jahr schon so versucht, aber man muss auch generell sagen,
das ist ja immer so, Demonstration, Demonstration, Demonstration, Beschlagnahmt.
Demonstration, Demonstration, Demonstration, Beschlagnahmt. Also dass wir immer
zwischendurch auch wieder gestoppt wurden.
Ich glaube, du übertreibst so viele Demonstrationen ohne Beschlagnahme, schafft ihr gar nicht.
Und dann ist es so, dass wir ja, also generell fährt der Bus rum und das Ziel ist es,
neben halt natürlich die AfD zu bekämpfen, wo wir sie treffen,
ist es ja auch lokale kleine Initiativen quasi zu boosten, groß zu machen und so weiter.
Also wir fahren ja nicht rum und machen die ganze Zeit selber Sachen,
sondern wir gucken auch, wo macht irgendwer was, Omas gegen Recht,
sonst irgendwas, AfD-Bürger-Dialog. Da sind ja überall kleine Strukturen von
kleinen Leuten überall im Land.
Jetzt gerade in Sachsen-Anhalt, demnächst auch in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern oder
auch jetzt natürlich immer in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern.
Und die sind klein, da treffen sich 30 Leute gegenüber vom AfD-Bürger-Dialog um hier ihren Unmut.
Und da fahren wir dann hin und machen quasi den kleinen Protest groß.
Da kommt dann der Bus hin, dann ist das aber immer in der Presse,
in der lokalen, ganz dick und so weiter.
Die freuen sich und es kommen auch von überall dann Leute angefahren,
weil sie den Bus eh schon immer mal sehen wollten.
Genau, nun ist es so, wir sind so wie die Coca-Cola-Weihnachtstour sozusagen, so eine Art in cool.
So eine Art Roadshow, ja, die quasi, da ist ein Team von Leuten im Bus,
Volunteers, dass die quasi sagen, ich will da mitfahren.
Und die fahren dann für ein oder zwei Wochen mit. Aber der Bus kommt nicht nach
Hause, der fährt immer weiter und weiter.
Und wir haben aber nicht jeden Tag Programm. Also wir haben nicht jeden Tag
irgendwas, wo wir zu einer lokalen Aktion hinfahren können.
Gerade wenn nicht so die Woche vor der Wahl ist wie jetzt.
Was auch der Grund ist, warum er jetzt nicht auf der Attention natürlich ist,
weil er ist da, wo er gebraucht wird, in Sachsen-Anhalt.
Und dann, nach der Attention, kommt er dann hierher. Weil dann ist ja zwei Wochen
bis zur Wahl in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern.
Aber weil man nicht jeden Tag was hat, haben wir dann überlegt,
was machen wir unter der Woche mit dem Bus? Also was macht man am Dienstag, am Mittwoch?
Und da haben wir gesagt, wir machen eine Schultour, weil wir sehr erschreckt
davon waren, dass die AfD bei diesen Jugendwahlen so viel Zuspruch hatte.
Denn ich weiß nicht, hier kommen ja Leute von überall her oder auch die Hörer
kommen von überall her, aber bei mir, als ich noch in der Schule war,
war das nicht so, dass die Leute irgendwie 20% NPD, gab es ja damals DVU und
so weiter, sondern das war eigentlich nicht vorhanden, weil das total uncool besetzt war.
Also es war einfach überhaupt nicht cool, rechts zu sein.
Und mal ganz dem Beiberg, es ist auch heute nicht cool.
Rechts zu sein.
Gut, dass du da noch was drauf hingewiesen hast. Aber manche Leute denken,
es sei cool, vielleicht.
Und das war erschreckend, weil ich glaube, da hat es Zahlen um die 20 Prozent,
in manchen Bundesländern mehr, in manchen weniger gegeben.
Und wir haben gedacht, hey, wir fahren an die Schulen. Und man konnte sich dann
melden. Es wurde sofort überbucht bis zum Gehtnichtmehr, die Anfragen von Schulen,
wo uns entweder Schüler bestellen können oder auch die Schule selbst.
Und dann gehen wir mit denen in Kontakt, dann sagen Schulen zu und dann kommen
wir für einen Tag dorthin. und parken auf dem Schulhof in aller Regel.
Und dort gibt es dann einerseits einen Vortrag über quasi, ja,
Verfassungsverhältigkeit AfD, rechte Tendenzen, Fake News auch.
Und es gibt so verschiedene Stationen, die wir aufbauen, wo es quasi so ein
Quiz mit Fake News, also die kriegen Videos gezeigt, ist das echt, ist das nicht echt.
Weil ja gerade jetzt in der aktuellen Zeit die Schule das überhaupt nicht hinkriegt,
Medienkompetenz richtig zu vermitteln.
Allerdings zeigen, meine ich, Studien, dass wenn man 15 Minuten Schulung macht
in Medienkompetenz, dann erkennt man schon 80% aller Fake News.
Und dass das unsere Schulsystem nicht selbst darstellt, ist wirklich krass.
Und das versuchen wir halt jetzt im ganz Kleinen. Das ist eine Schule,
in Deutschland gibt es viele Schulen.
Aber so nutzen wir unsere Off-Times.
Wenn du sagst Schule, an welche Klassen geht ihr da ran? An was für Schulen geht ihr ran?
Das Programm richtet sich an Sekundarstufe 2 und 3. Das heißt...
Das hat sich ja viel verändert mit 12 und 13. Ich denke, es richtet sich ab
der 7.8. Klasse bis dann aufwärts. Also an Leute im Alter zwischen 14,
15 und halt Ende der Schule.
Kinder, die auch schon ihren Nachnamen tanzen können.
Auch, ja genau, das ist für die Waldorfschule, genau, und alle anderen können
natürlich auch kommen und gucken, also es gibt dann in den Pausen, gucken alle.
Und das ist aber auch, also für die Crews, die da fahren, ist das ein ziemlich
cooles Erlebnis, weil viel Wertschätzung da ist, das sind ja nun,
es gibt viele Schulen, die sagen, hey, nee, hier Neutralitätsgebot, wir dürfen das nicht.
Aber es gibt auch viele Schulleitungen und Lehrer- und Schülervertretungen,
die sagen, nee, ihr kommt hierher und die auch dann so einen Druck selbst im
Osten, wo die AfD stark ist, aushalten und sagen, nee, nee, hier entscheiden wir das.
Und zum Thema Neutralitätsgebot, nur mal ganz, um es anzureißen,
ist ein Riesenthema. Es gibt so eine, wie heißt das denn?
Beutelsbacher Konsens. Und dort heißt es, man darf Kinder nicht indoktrinieren.
Aber was wir machen, ist keine Indoktrination, sondern eigentlich so quasi politische
Teilhabe, politische Bildung. Die können ja selber sich entscheiden,
wie sie diese Fakten bewerten.
Und ich verweise immer gerne auf den Paragraf 1 des Schulgesetzes des Landes Berlin.
Das ist nämlich der Auftrag der Schule. Und das ist ähnlich in allen Schulgesetzen.
In Berlin ist es sehr, sehr konkret, kommt bestimmt in die Shownotes.
Aber die Aufgabe der Schule ist es, solche Menschen heranzuziehen,
zu ziehen, die dem Nationalsozialismus und allen verwandten Ideologien entschieden entgegentreten.
So, das ist die Aufgabe der Schule. Und...
Und da kann man jetzt viel über Beutelsbacher Dialoge, Beutelsbacher Konzert reden.
Es ist einfach eine Bemühung von einem völlig sachfremden anderen Thema,
um quasi solche Themen aus der Schule rauszuhalten.
Ich glaube, diese juristische Kurzfassung, da gibt es auch einen Vortrag bei
dem CCC-Kongress, den wir verlinken, der sich mit dem sogenannten Neutralitätsgebot
auseinandersetzt, das es in den meisten Fällen einfach überhaupt nicht gibt.
Aber es wird der Schule oder dem Lehrpersonal ist,
streng angehalten die demokratischen Prinzipien zu vertreten und nicht aktiv
gegen einzelne Parteien sich zu äußern also man kann einen Adenauer SRP der
das ist er auch nicht, das ist ein.
Anderer es kommt hier gerade so ein anderer Demo zum,
Wahnsinnsfahrzeug aber laut.
Wie viele Schulen habt ihr jetzt schon gemacht?
Könnte ich dir nicht sagen. Das ist ja auch so. Das sind zwei bis drei die Woche.
Oder manchmal auch vier. Da haben wir gesagt, das ist ganz schön viel.
Wenn du da zu so einer Schule fährst, musst du da um 7.30 Uhr sein.
Fürchterliche Einrichtungen. Fürchterliche Einrichtungen. Ich habe schreckliche Erinnerungen.
Die sagen dann so, wir wollen in der zweiten Stunde dahin zum Bus.
Es sind nur 8.40 Uhr. Und du warst aber vorher, anderthalb Stunden Arbeit aufzuhören.
Muss da irgendwie noch hinfahren und so weiter. Das heißt, dann geht so ein
Tag um 5 Uhr los und dann sagen die aber in aller Regel auch noch,
ja und nach der Schule, so um 14 Uhr ist dann Schule aus oder um 15 Uhr,
dann dürfen die Eltern kommen und gucken und dann geht so ein Tag halt mega lang.
Deswegen haben wir am Anfang vier gemacht und ich glaube, jetzt sind wir so
bei zwei bis drei, die man dann die Woche so anfährt in Zeiten, wo dafür Zeit ist.
Und wenn das Auto nicht beschlagnahmt ist.
Genau, wenn es gerade nicht beschlagnahmt ist. Und wie viele,
keine Ahnung, wir wären jetzt bei 40 gewesen. Also ich, was auch immer ich hier
sage, ich bin inkompetent zur Menge.
Wie läuft das so konkret ab, wenn ihr dann sozusagen da in den Dialog tritt?
Macht ihr das dann im Bus oder geht ihr in die Klassen rein,
redet ihr mit allen oder einzeln Gruppchen, Bildung?
Das ist so, dass die Lehrer, das wird in den Unterricht eingebettet,
das gibt von uns begleitendes Material, es gibt sogar ein Schulheft dazu von uns,
und die Lehrer, die das also angemeldet haben, die Klassen, die ausgewählt sind,
das zu machen, die Jahrgänge, die sind angehalten, das vorzubereiten.
Hausaufgabe.
Deutsche Schule.
Nazis raus, Klassenarbeit.
Nazis raus, Klassenarbeit, genau. Die sind angehalten, das vorzubereiten,
gewissermaßen, was kommt da, um das zu kontextualisieren.
Und dann kommen die als Gruppen, manchmal ist auch in der Aula der Vortrag vor
ganz vielen, und dann kommen die in Gruppen zum Bus, dürfen sich den Bus angucken
und die Stationen machen und dort geht es dann so ins Gespräch,
aber das sind dann eher auf Klassenbasis, sag ich jetzt mal.
Wart ihr auch schon mal an der Waldorfschule?
Weil die können ja schon seit der ersten Klasse ihren Namen tanzen.
Da kann man ja ganz früh anfangen.
Wie heißt das andere? Montessori waren wir aus Waldorf noch nicht.
Aber das ist auch so, die Schulen holen uns.
Also die Frage ist viel besser, hat euch schon mal eine Waldorfschule geholt? Also eingeladen.
Und die Antwort ist nein. Irgendwie bin ich nicht überrascht.
Die Vorbereitung wäre dann, dass man Adenauer tanzt.
Spoiler, man tanzt seinen Namen übrigens gar nicht auf der Schule,
aber es interessiert weil du da nicht hingegangen bist zu.
Eurythmie oder wie das.
Heißt das ist Zwangsprogramm da muss jeder, wie stellst du das überhaupt vor ich dachte.
Das würde nicht stattfinden, Namen tanzen gut Tim ist jetzt auch nicht wirklich ein Tanz.
Das sieht schon ganz gut aus. Nicht so elend wie Linus.
Linus ist, ja. Meine Eltern wollten extra einen Namen, dem man scheiße tanzen kann.
Naja, auf jeden Fall. Ich hoffe, da melden sich auch noch mal ein paar,
weil ich glaube, die könnten es auch ganz gut gebrauchen. Die glauben ja auch
an so Schwurbelkram. Und wer an Schwurbelkram glaubt, ist er eh schon verloren.
Wir sind Nazi-Esoteriker.
Teilweise. 20 Prozent von denen.
Aber 20 Prozent von allen sind Nazi-Esoteriker.
Naja.
Anyway, kommen wir mal zu diesem Sonderfahrzeug.
Wir haben uns ja sehr viel damit auseinandergesetzt. Der Adenauer ist reichlich
bebaut und auch in der ersten Folge haben wir viel darüber gesprochen,
was dieses Fahrzeug alles ziert.
Aber vielleicht magst du ja mal so die häufigsten Prüfanlässe,
was jetzt so an diesem Fahrzeug,
dem ungeübten Polizisten, der denkt, ich halte jetzt mal so ein Auto an,
was versucht der als erstes zu bemängeln an dem Bus?
Ja, der übliche Polizist ist erstmal extrem überfordert, weil der,
das habe ich jetzt dann auch gelernt, in der Polizei gibt es die Verkehrsstaffel,
die quasi damit befasst ist, den Schwerverkehr zu kontrollieren.
Und das ist ja Schwerverkehr, 18 Tonnen Zulassung.
Und die Ausbildung dahin ist zweimal acht Stunden Lehrgang. Dann gehörst du
zur Verkehrshundertschaft der Polizei.
Und damit stehst du dann über...
Diplomingenieuren, weil du quasi das bewertest, was andere berechnet haben.
Aber aus der Sicht des einzelnen Polizisten macht es dich zu quasi Gott über
alles. Du weißt alles besser dann automatisch. Grundregel, wenn du bei der Verkehrshundertschaft bist.
Ich glaube, das ist Grundregel, wenn du bei der Polizei bist.
Genau, das stimmt auch. Und dann kommt so ein Polizist und fängt an, Dinge zu benörgeln.
Da geht's, der fängt, ja, was bemängeln die? Also bei uns ist es ja vor allem,
der Dachaufbau, der bemängelt wird.
Dann wird gesagt, das kann doch gar nicht sein. Dann muss man denen immer erst
erklären, wo ist denn eigentlich Ladung? Also der Unterschied ist Ladung und Bus.
Wo fängt Ladung an? Wo ist Bus? Wie ist das befestigt? Warum ist das Ladung?
Sowas ist ein Thema. Wie ist nachgewiesen, dass das hält?
Und normalerweise, wenn man, glaube ich, so irgendeine Art von Transport macht,
so ein LKW oder sowas und man lädt da Ladung drauf oder man hat einen Anhänger, dann wird man so einmal,
alle zwei Millionen Kilometer einer solchen Kontrolle unterzogen und wir halt
einmal alle zwei Kilometer.
Aber was haben die denn da zu bemängeln? Also ich meine, es ist doch bestimmt
ganz gut untersucht worden, das Fahrzeug.
Genau, und dann ist es auch meistens so, diese Kontrollen finden meistens so
statt, dass dann irgendwas bemängelt wird. Am Ende heißt es dann,
ihr dürft weiterfahren.
Dann gibt es da so einen Mängelschein, der geht dann an die Ordnungsbehörde
in Berlin und die Ordnungsbehörde in Berlin muss dann sagen,
nö, haben wir aber schon überprüft.
So, das ist immer das gleiche, für solche Mängelscheine haben wir mittlerweile fast 600. 6?
Ist das dein Ernst?
Nicht ganz, nicht ganz. Okay, ist nicht dein Ernst.
Aber ich sag mal, deutlich, also 1,02, aber deutlich über 60 und das Fahrzeug
gibt es seit, also letztlich käme man, letztlich käme man, also an manchen Tagen haben wir zwei.
Scheine, nicht Mängel.
Und im Landesamt für Bürger- und Ordnungsangelegenheiten in Berlin ist das quasi
eine Person, die das bearbeitet.
Die wirft das immer einfach alles weg.
Nicht nur, aber...
Gelesen, gelacht, gelocht, abgeheftet.
Gelesen, gelacht, gelocht, nicht gelesen. Da kommen wir auch später noch ein
bisschen mehr zu, weil die ja teilweise sich auch so einen impertinenten Drang
entwickeln, dann nachzufassen nochmal. Das ist so innerbehördliche Kommunikation,
die werden wir ein bisschen beleuchten nachher noch.
Innerbehördliche und zwischen Prominenten und Behörden.
Aber ihr habt doch da bestimmt auch schon ein paar Gutachten gemacht.
Ja.
So, habt ihr die dann nicht ausgedruckt dabei?
Doch.
Deutsche mag doch so ausgedrucktes.
Und das ist so, das sind vier so Leitsordner.
Weil, so ein Gutachten ist lang. Also wir haben technische Berechnungen,
wir haben Statikberechnungen, wir haben eine sogenannte FM-Analyse.
Also da geht es darum, dass quasi die Schrauben und die Dinger,
mit denen das Dachteil drauf ist, also,
die Vierkantrohre und Schrauben und dann wird quasi das in so eine Simulation
eingegeben und dann wird berechnet in so Fahrzeugtechnik, wenn das die ganze
Zeit so hin und her schwankt, dann gibt es so dynamische Geschichten und wie
sehr wird das belastet und hält das das am Ende aus.
Sowas ist dann 40 Seiten lang und dann werden diese ganzen Teile so leicht rot-gelb
im Laufe der Analyse und die dürfen halt einen bestimmten Wert dann nicht überschreiten.
Da haben wir, also wir haben relativ viele Gutachten gemacht,
die man nachrechnen kann, wenn man das möchte.
Aber mit acht Stunden Lehrgang kann man das ja kurz nachrechnen.
Der Polizist kann das halt genau nicht, sozusagen. Der kann nicht das hokische
Gesetz nochmal überprüfen.
Nicht? Den dritten Euler-Fall und sowas. Das ist wirklich Physik.
Was können die eigentlich?
Ja, die können vor allem Mängelscheine schreiben.
Können sie sehr gut, weil dann teilweise steht dann auch noch,
da wird falsch angekreuzt. Also wir könnten das ausstellen, aber man darf es nicht.
Aber dann teilweise wird Kreuzen, die können noch nicht mal ihren Mängelschein korrekt ausfüllen.
Sie können noch nicht mal richtig beschlagnahmen. Das ist eigentlich das Ding,
also ja, die können noch nicht mal richtig beschlagnahmen.
Denn als der Bus da beschlagnahmt wurde, in Chemnitz zum Beispiel,
wurde das einfach über die falsche Gesetz.
Also es war ja sowieso illegal und es wurde vorgetäuscht, es hätte eine richtige...
Wie geht denn das normalerweise und wie machen die es?
Wie darf man normalen Bus beschlagen haben?
Ja, also was müssten sie eigentlich tun?
Döbeln dann jetzt.
Vielleicht erklären wir kurz. Also ihr wart unterwegs zum CSD Döbeln.
Christopher Street Day in Döbeln.
Genau.
Eine Demonstration, die ihr unterstützen wolltet.
Ja.
Auf dem Weg dorthin wurdet ihr angehalten.
Genau.
Um kurz die Dimensionen. Also
wie oft wurde der angehalten? Du hattest mal beim Kongress so ein Video.
Ich kann es dir nicht mehr erzählen. Das ist so, wie du fragst,
wie viele Zigaretten hast du letzte Woche geraucht?
Aber über 100 Mal?
Er wurde oft angehalten. Ja, natürlich, aber das ist ja auch so.
Das ist ja ein Unterschied.
Angehalten und Stress oder angehalten und okay, wo wollt ihr hin?
Wir gleiten jetzt da hin. Aber ich habe keine so eine Strichliste angehalten,
ehrlich gesagt. Die habe ich nicht.
Wir sind beim CSD Christopher Street Day in Döbeln eingeladen worden,
als Lautsprecherwagen mitzufahren.
Und wir waren sogar nicht auf dem Weg dahin, sondern wir waren schon da.
Wir waren am Ort, wo der CSD in Döbeln startet, am Bahnhof in Döbeln.
Und ich bin am Bahnhof in Döbeln ausgestiegen und habe den Polizisten gefragt,
ist hier, wir waren eine halbe Stunde, wir waren Erster, ist hier Erster in Döbeln.
Genau, nur wer Erster in Döbeln ist, ist es richtig in Döbeln.
Dann bin ich zum Polizisten hingegangen und habe gesagt, wir sind vom Adenauer,
das konnte er sich auch schon vorstellen, der Bus war ja da,
und wir wollen jetzt hier aufbauen.
Und dann hat der mir gesagt, nee, das startet aber nicht hier.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, hä, aber hier steht Badefügel, nee,
aber das ist auch andere Seite, ihr müsst da langfahren.
Und dann wurden wir quasi weggeleitet unter Vortäuschung falscher Tatsachen.
Gibt Zeitungsfotos, die uns schon am Startpunkt sehen. Und dann wurden wir so,
nee, das ist da hinten. So ganz blitt weggeleitet und dann wurden wir von Polizei
in den Schlepptau genommen und so ganz noch weiter weggeleitet und dann angehalten
mitten auf der Bundesstraße.
Und genau, und dort, die Frage war jetzt, wie man es richtig beschlagnahmen
würde und wie man es falsch.
Also erstmal richtig kannst du ein Fahrzeug, was schon auf einer Demo angekommen
ist, es kann ja schon gar keine Gefährst, also es nimmt ja schon gar nicht mehr am Verkehr teil.
Wenn der Verantwortliche kommt und sagt, ich bin hier für die Demonstration,
ich baue auf, dann nimmt es ja schon gar nicht am Verkehr mehr teil.
Also da kannst du schon mal gar nicht mehr. Du kannst es dann gar nicht mehr
beschlagnahmen. Du kannst es dann danach wieder vielleicht, nach der Demonstration.
Aber während der Demonstration kannst du es nicht beschlagnahmen.
Da muss es nicht der STVO entsprechen. Und vor allem gibt es einen Grundsatz,
das nennt sich Polizeifestigkeit von Versammlungen. Ist ein Rechtsgrundsatz.
Und da geht es darum, dass die Polizei sich in extremer Weise zurückhalten muss,
um so eine Versammlungslage nicht zu stören. Da geht es ja um die Grundrechtsausübung.
Und da müssen so Sachen wie STVO, STVZO, bla, das muss dem alles nachstehen.
Und entweder muss die Polizei sagen, nein, das Fahrzeug ist so gefährlich,
dass es jetzt nicht im Schritttempo mit Ordnern drumrum hier mitfahren kann,
weil es explodieren wird. So.
Dann können sie auch sagen, geht nicht. Aber sonst musst du es eigentlich erst
mal mitfahren und dann kannst du deine Maßnahmen nach. Also geht schon mal gar nicht.
Richtig beschlagnahmt im Straßenverkehr wäre,
Ich halte dich an, ich stelle was fest.
Also ich, die Polizei.
Du, die Polizei hältst mich an, du stellst was fest.
Und dann stellt sich die Frage, ist das jetzt Gefahr im Verzug und gibt es keinen Richter und nichts?
Dann könntest du sagen, die Gefahr erscheint mir so groß, dass ich das jetzt hier beschlagnahme.
Und dann kann der Gegner, also der Bus quasi, dagegen Rechtsmittel am nächsten
Tag beim nächsten Gericht einwerfen.
Bei so einer Versammlung gibt es Bereitschaftsrichter.
Das heißt, du müsstest dann der Richterin sagen, in dem Fall war es eine Richterin,
sagen, hab hier einen Bus, ist gefährlich, bitte einmal Beschlagnahmen.
Und dann sagt die Richterin, okay, Beschlagnahmen.
Oder?
Oder sie sagt halt nein. Und du musst aber der Richterin auch alle Informationen
vorlegen. Du kannst also nicht sagen, dein Bus ist ganz gefährlich,
aber der Halter hat dir gerade vier Haufen Gutachten bekommen.
Eins davon eine Woche alt, wo drauf steht, ohne Mängel.
Im Auftrag des Landes Berlin erstellt.
Das musst du der Richterin schon auch sagen. Du kannst nicht sagen,
hier ist ein Bus, ganz komisch, so ein luftleerer Raum.
Sondern du musstest schon sagen, hier ist ein Bus, mir erscheint der nicht verkehrssicher.
Aber ich bin nur die Verkehrshundertschaft. Aber vor einer Woche hat die DEKRA-Niederlassung
Berlin alles geprüft und hat gesagt, der ist ohne Mängel.
Und so zulässig. Und dann muss die Richterin. Und das hat dieser Polizist nicht
gemacht. Er hat einfach gesagt, du kannst du verkehrssicher.
Wir haben gleichzeitig gesagt, wir hätten gerne ebenfalls Kontakt zu der Richterin,
um auch einen Vortrag machen zu können, also um sagen zu können,
hier sind nochmal ein bisschen Informationen von uns.
Der wurde uns verwehrt und jetzt kommt's, das Schlimme ist, eigentlich dann
sagt die Richterin okay, aber in dem Fall hat die Richterin gesagt,
nein, du kannst den Bus nicht beschlagnahmen, Ringo.
Und dann wurde uns gesagt, ihr kriegt keinen Kontakt zur Richterin,
wir wissen auch nicht, wer die ist, aber sie hat es bestätigt.
Was, die haben sozusagen die Unwahrheit gesagt darüber, was tatsächlich passiert ist.
Bis heute behaupten sie, die Richterin Polkowski hätte gesagt,
man darf beschlagnahmen, aber die Richterin schreibt in der Akte,
ich habe fünfmal zu dem Thema telefoniert, ich habe gesagt, das kann ich so nicht entscheiden.
Und beim letzten Gespräch habe ich ausdrücklich gesagt, nein,
ihr dürft den Bus nicht beschlagnahmen. Ja doch, genau.
Also du hattest ja gefragt, wie man es nicht macht.
Aber das ist ja ganz schön kompliziert. Da bräuchte man eigentlich so eine Handreichung.
Ja. So eine Handreichung?
Wir kommen erstmal, jetzt wird die Karre beschlagnahmt.
Ja.
Dann wird die abgeschleppt?
Genau. Dann wird irgendwann rausgeworfen, nö, das ist ja so gefährlich,
das kannst du eigentlich fast gar nicht machen.
Aber sie haben ihn halt auf eigener Achse. Ein Abschleppdienst kommt,
setzt sie in den Bus und fährt damit.
Und zwar 70 in der 50-Zone, 100 in der 80. So gefährlich war das.
Ich muss noch mal kurz nachfragen. Wusstet ihr zu dem Zeitpunkt,
dass die Richterin Nein gesagt hat?
Nein, das ist alles erst mit der Akte gekommen. Das ist übrigens das Schöne
dann doch in Deutschland.
Du kriegst dann so Akten und du glaubst gar nicht, was da alles drin steht.
Das muss ja alles dokumentiert werden, die muss vollständig sein und da kriegst
du diese ganzen Quatsch hin.
Die Polizei war sogar so kompetent, dass sie es über die Falsche,
sie hätte über den in dem Fall Landkreis Mittelsachsen die Beschlagnahme anordnen
müssen, hat es aber über irgendeine Chemnitz-Geschichte gemacht,
einfach falscher Behördenweg.
Dazu steht in der Akte, dass der Herr Schneider, der Verkehrspolizist,
das kritisch reflektieren wird. Das ist ja das Falsche.
Das ist ja schön.
Ja, also er reflektiert kritisch und ich habe keinen Bus mehr.
Und jetzt hat er den beschlagnahmt, dann kam der irgendwie wieder nach Berlin.
Ja, dann durften wir den, also erstmal beschlagnahmt, weil es ist ja komplett
verkehrs- und sie haben ja gerade schon angetextet.
Und dann denkt man, da kommt ein Abschleppdienst, der wird auf so einen Tieflader
und gefährlich und dann Polizei drumherum, dass der auch gar nicht explodiert.
Und der Fakt ist immer, da kommt ein Absteppdienst, setzt sich vorne rein,
macht den Motor an und fährt dann mit 100 Kilometern nach Chemnitz.
Wir haben Tracking im Bus, da wo 50 erlaubt ist mit 70, da wo 80 da mit 100.
Und das scheint ja wirklich wahnsinnig gefährlich zu sein, das Fahrzeug.
Ja, deswegen ist er auch so schnell.
Aber schnell fahren. Merke, wenn dein Fahrzeug irgendwie komische Sachen macht, gib Gas.
Genau. Und dann steht er da in Chemnitz in der Ring und wir durften ihn dann,
dann wurde er dort von der Dekra begutachtet von einer sehr voreingenommenen,
sehr mittelsächsischen Dekra-Filiale mit entsprechenden Prüfern,
die dann alle möglichen Mutmaßungen, die haben nichts wirklich geprüft,
aber sie haben halt gesagt, der ist verkehrsunsicher.
Und die Fragestellung war die, kann der was auf dem Dach haben?
Dann haben die bei Mercedes angerufen und haben gesagt, ja, gibt's eine Dachlast?
Und dann hat Mercedes gesagt, das haben wir nicht geprüft.
Und daraus ergibt sich dann, alles klar, das ist 0 Kilo dann.
Also wenn man es nicht geprüft hat, das ist 0 Kilo.
Das heißt, ein Schneeflocke, also eigentlich wäre so eine Dekra,
die müsste dann sagen, dann prüfe ich das jetzt.
Beziehungsweise, ich lese mal die vier Ordner, weil da ist es ja genau geprüft worden und berechnet.
Und man kann nicht nur sagen vom Hersteller, der hat mir angedacht und dann
steht da drin, die Dachlast steht in dem Dekra, in der Handreichung, 0 Kilo.
Und das heißt wirklich, eine Schneeflocke reicht schon und der Bus wird in sich zusammenstürzen.
Das passiert täglich auf deutschen Straßen.
In Bayern ist das im Winter das häufigste Bustod.
Und das Witzige ist, aber nur unser Bus hat 0 Kilo, weil alle anderen Busse
müssen per Gesetz so gebaut sein, dass die selber aus 1 Meter Höhe auf ihr eigenes
Dach fallen. Ihr kennt ja die Bilder aus Tagesschau, wenn wieder auf der A9
ein Doppeldecker umgekippt ist.
Also alle anderen Busse schaffen es, ihre eigenen 18 Tonnen auf ihr,
wenn man die verkehrt rum hinlegt, zu halten.
Aber unsere eine Schneeflocke vorbei.
Jetzt war der in Chemnitz, jetzt haben die Chemnitzer Dekra-Prüfer Pi mal Daumen
geschätzt, 0 Kilo Dachlast. Und dann?
Ja, dann durften wir den, dann haben wir dann quasi den Bus,
es war so gefährlich mit unserer Dachlast, dass wir den Bus nur ohne Dachlast,
auch nur schleppen, also es war so, stillgelegt, wir haben den Fahrzeugschein,
das ist auch schon unüblich, zurückbekommen,
später von der Zulagungsstelle und der Polizist hatte so quer über den Fahrzeugschein
geschrieben, zerstört.
Eigentlich muss das ein Stempel drauf entwert. Also zerstört.
Stand quer über dem Fahrzeugschein.
Und damit war der dann zerstört worden.
Der Bus ist so gefährlich, ihr dürft den nur auf einem Tieflader nach Berlin zurückholen.
Aber auch nicht mit dem Dachaufbau, sondern das muss auf einen extra Tieflader.
Und dann haben wir den so abgeholt nach Berlin.
Dann haben wir ihn zur DEKRA gebracht. Dann haben wir den Dachträger wieder
drauf gemacht, neue Papiere gekommen und durften wieder weiterfahren. Das war, genau.
Aber da war ja die Polizei Chemnitz wahrscheinlich gar nicht so happy mit.
Überhaupt gar nicht.
Was haben die denn?
Das ist das Lustige, was jetzt so aus der Akte kommt, denn die Polizei Chemnitz
hat sich dann quasi, sie hat quasi eigentlich so eine richtige Soko gegründet.
Wir müssen wissen, hier geht es, die Polizeidirektion Chemnitz ist zuständig
für so Mittelsachsen, Erzgebirgskreis und so weiter.
Aber die haben so eine neue, so eine deutschlandweite Zuständigkeit für alles
entwickelt dann in ihrer Polizeidirektion.
Und haben gesagt, wir machen die
ganze Zeit Stress bei der Berliner Verkehrsstelle, also beim Berliner Amt.
Und haben die ganze Zeit E-Mails dahin geschickt. Jetzt ist der Bus gerade in Gießen beim AfD.
Jetzt ist er beim DEKRA. Also richtig so mit unseren Social-Media-Kanälen und
immer gesagt, jetzt ist er da.
Jetzt müsst ihr den wieder stilllegen. Und dann hat die Zulassungsstelle auch
in den E-Mails drin immer so zurückgeschrieben. ja, aber wir haben doch alles
geprüft, das ist doch alles in Ordnung.
Und dann so, nein, was sollen wir denn machen? Und dann schreibt er zurück,
Das hast du, glaube ich, irgendwo, oder?
Die Idee war, dass sie ohne vorherige Anhörung eine Betriebsuntersagung mit
sofortiger Vollziehung erlassen und man den Bus dann vor Abfahrt in Gießen von
Amts wegen außer Betrieb setzt.
Ausrufezeichen, Ausrufezeichen.
Das war die Idee.
Das war die Idee. Das steht so in der E-Mail von der Polizei Sachsen an die
Behörde in Berlin über einen Bus, der in Berlin zugelassen ist und sich in Gießen befindet.
Und die Berliner, der Mitarbeiter der Berliner Zulassungsbehörde sagt,
es mag dabei ihrer Auffassung widersprechen, dennoch ist meine Behörde aufgrund
der vorgelegten Unterlagen zu der Auffassung gelangt, dass sich das Fahrzeug
in einem zulassungsfähigen Zustand befindet.
So, jetzt kämpft also, jetzt kämpft die Berliner Behörde für die Gültigkeit ihrer Zulassung.
Und diese Chemnitzer Polizei, oder ist es hauptsächlich ein Polizist?
Ja, also das ist Ringo Schneider, ist in dem Verkehrsthema. Es gibt jetzt mittlerweile
noch einen zweiten, der mich persönlich jagt, Manuel Müller.
Also der jagt mich wegen dem Verwenden verfassungsfeindlicher oder terroristischer. Komm mal gleich zu.
Komm mal, komm mal.
Genau, aber da gibt es zwei mit einer auf der verkehrsrechtlichen Schiene,
das ist Ringo Schneider, und der andere auf der strafrechtlichen Schiene gegen mich persönlich.
Und jetzt haben die, hätten sie natürlich sagen können, naja okay,
die Karre ist in Berlin zugelassen worden, gut, kann man nichts machen,
unsere DEKRA-Prüfer haben die Akten nicht gelesen.
Aber nein, denn sie entwickeln tatsächlich eine Handlungsanweisung, ne?
Ja, die ist auch in den Akten drin.
Würden wir niemals hier zeigen.
Wir dürfen die hier gar nicht zeigen, weil man darf Akteninnahmlich sagen und
die ist auch vor allem nur für den Dienstgebrauch.
Verschlusssache.
Wir können euch nur daraus berichten, was wir darin sehen.
Also was quasi diese Handlungsanleitung ist, ist eine 14-seitige Anleitung,
wie aus Sicht von diesen Polizisten in Chemnitz mit unserem Bus umzugehen ist.
Es enthält ein Kontrollschema, wo wir angehalten werden sollen,
was dann zu untersagen ist.
Ist ein richtiger Flowchart drin, also mit so Ja-Nein, so ein Handlungsschema.
Ist der gerade auf einer Demo?
Ja, dann noch nicht, sondern dann warten und nach der Demo beschlagnahmen.
Und das haben die geschickt an sämtliche Polizeien in Deutschland inklusive
der GSG 9 Antiterroreinheit.
Jetzt gibt es ein Problem an der ganzen Geschichte,
weil die Handlungsanleitung enthält auf Seite 1 ein Bild von unserem Bus,
wie er beim AfD-Parteitag in Riesa steht. Das ist das Titelbild.
Und das Problem ist, an dem Bild halten wir die ausschließlichen Nutzungsrechte,
weil wir es selbst fotografiert haben.
Es wurde von unserer Webseite runtergeklaut.
Und wir haben ja viele so rechtliche Auseinandersetzungen. Und ich habe jetzt
gelernt, das Urheberrecht zu lieben.
Weil da sind die Sachen eigentlich klar, da musst du nicht viel diskutieren.
Sondern da musst du eine Unterlassungserklärung unterschreiben.
Die wir euch auch nie hier zeigen würden.
Die ist unterschrieben vom Polizeipräsident Carsten Kempf aus Chemnitz.
Und damit geht ein Herr des Carsten Chemnitz, der hat ja... Carsten Chemnitz,
Carsten Kempf. Aber Carsten Chemnitz ist eigentlich gut.
Oder?
Carsten Chemnitz kämpft jetzt, weil Carsten Kempf hat mit so einer Geschichte...
Also wenn ihr das seht, also wenn ihr jetzt...
Ihr wollt jetzt nicht in der Rolle von Carsten Kempf sein.
Weil Carsten Kempf, wenn man einfach Fotos von jemand anderem klaut und in eine
eigene interne Handlungsanweisung und die an ganz Deutschland an die Polizei verschickt.
Das ist eine Vervielfältigung.
Das ist eine Vervielfältigung. Und das heißt, es gibt verschiedene Fristen,
die er jetzt einhalten muss. Das war die erste Frist, die ist erledigt.
Hat er unterschrieben? Check.
Aber jetzt muss er bis morgen leider uns auch noch berichten,
in welcher Art und Weise an wen er sie verschickt hat komplett,
an wen die weitergeleitet wurden.
Und muss alle, an die er sie weitergeleitet hat, informieren,
unter Verweis auf die Rechtswidrigkeit des Ganzen, dass sie das auf keinen Fall
weiter verbreiten wird.
Außerdem muss Carsten Kempf dafür Sorge tragen, dass das Ding überall gelöscht wird.
Genau, dass das Ding überall gelöscht wird. Und dokumentieren,
wie es gelöscht ist. Und dann als drittes, er muss ja sagen,
wo wurde es verwendet? In welcher Menge wird es gedruckt?
Das dient dazu, dass wir dann festlegen können, wie viel er uns bezahlen muss
als Lizenzierung für das Bild, weil er hat es ja nun schon, das Kind ist ja im Brunnen.
Ist schon lizenziert worden im Prinzip.
Übrigens, für den Podcast, für den Titel, ihr dürft das benutzen.
Wir haben das schon mal.
Aber wir haben das ja auch, wir haben das vorher angefragt, Wir haben ja die Rechte von euch.
Kein Problem, euch räumen wir die gerne ein, aber Carsten Kempf nicht.
Warum nur?
Dazu kommt, er hat jetzt Fristen, die laufen, ich teaser es schon mal an,
aber wir haben auch eine schöne Webseite, die heißt heyringo.de,
die gibt es seit gestern.
Da sind noch mal alle Fristen von Carsten Kempf aufgelistet,
wie viele Tage er noch hat.
Denn es ist interessant, Und die Polizei ist zusätzlich, also weil der Inhalt
der Handlungsanweisung ist dazu noch überholt.
Also die lassen, das ist eine tendenziöse Geschichte, die schreiben da einfach
nur das Gutachten, also die haben ihre lokalen Prüferchen aus Chemnitz,
die haben das und das und das festgestellt.
Und seitdem hat es etliche weitere Untersuchungen gegeben, die da völlig klargestellt
haben, alles voll in Ordnung.
Und die verschicken nun noch gar nicht lange her, es ist keine sechs Wochen
her, einfach an alle Polizeien in Deutschland eine Informationslage,
die das nicht widerspiegelt, obwohl sie das wissen, sondern machen das selektiv.
Und deswegen hat er auch noch weitere, das haben wir dann nachgeschoben,
also im ersten Schritt war Urheberrecht. Carsten Kempf muss jetzt erstmal hier,
Urheberrechtssachen machen.
Und der hat dann sicherlich, weil er hat es ja unterschrieben,
er hat sicherlich schon alle informiert, hey, hier ist die Handlungsanweisung
jetzt mit neuem Foto, aber inhaltlich ändert sich nichts.
Jetzt kommt die nächste.
Aber leider haben wir schon die
nächste auf, dann haben wir fünf Tage gewartet, bis er das gemacht hat.
Und jetzt hat er eine neue Frist, das ist auch inhaltlich. Jetzt muss er eine
neue E-Mail schreiben. Ja, inhaltlich ist es auch nicht, richtig.
Also eigentlich müsste es löschen.
Kannst du mal noch kurz...
Ich habe mal kurz die Webseite aufgerufen, die ist ganz toll hier.
Hey Ringo, der Bus fährt immer weiter und der Faktencheck macht die Akte heiter.
Camps Fristenticker ist dann hier unter anderem und ich sehe gerade,
die nächsten drei Fristen sind ja nur noch in zwei Tagen.
Das stimmt, genau. Also der hat jetzt, zwei ist noch nicht nur noch ein Tag,
ich glaube eine läuft morgen um zwölf, oder?
Ne, hier steht Handlungsanleitung, Widerrufen plus Unterlassung noch zwei Tage.
Ah ja, hat er noch zwei Tage.
Foto löschen und Rückruf noch zwei Tage und Auskunft und Nachweise erteilen noch zwei Tage.
Ja, die fristen jetzt alle in zwei Tagen. Genau, der hat jetzt,
also Carsten Kempf hat echt viel, viel, das steht auch drüber.
Und vor allem heute ist Donnerstag.
Genau. Ja, ja, und Carsten Kempf, das steht glaube ich drüber,
Carsten Kempf hat viel zu tun gerade, oder?
Das ist auf jeden Fall.
Genau, das ist auch, Herr Ringo kann nicht nur das, Herr Ringo hat auch übrigens
eine KI, da kann man Fragen stellen und Ringo Schneider, der Polizist,
antwortet seine Version aufgrund der Akte und dann kommt die Richtigstellung.
Außerdem haben wir ein Spiel, wo man Ringo Schneider spielen kann und mit seinem
Motorrad den Adenauer jagen, aber es gibt in dem Spiel noch andere Figuren,
nämlich es gibt den Staatsanwalt, wenn der kommt, wird der Bus langsamer, weil der hilft ja Ringo.
Dann gibt's Justitia die Gerechtigkeit und das Recht an der kommt Ringo halt
nicht vorbei das ist das Problem, die schützt also den Bus und es gibt einen
Journalist, der kommt dann ins Bild,
Und der Journalist jagt Ringo wiederum. Das ist ein wirklich lustiges Spiel,
ist ab sofort spielbar. Kann ich nur wirklich allen empfehlen.
Genau, selbst, wir haben ja so ein bisschen ein Tracking drin.
Und das ist auch sehr beliebt bei der Polizei Sachsen, das Spiel.
Ein schönes Wer-wild-Millionär-Quiz habt ihr auch noch?
Genau.
Welche Prüforganisation bescheinigte dem Bus am 4.2.25 keine Mängel?
A, TÜV Nord, B, ADAC, C, Stiftung Warentest, D, Ringos Bauchgefühl.
Das sind die, ihr kennt vielleicht, es gibt diese 500 Euro Fragen und dann so
weiter, das wird richtig schwierig. Also ihr checkt das aus,
wer wird Aktenmillionär, gibt's auch auf heyringo.de. Also heyringo.de,
neue, das neue Kika.
Ihr habt jetzt den Bus wieder nach Berlin. Wie kriegst du denn diese Dachlast
geprüft? Du hast mir wunderschöne Fotos mal gezeigt, wo du den Bus mal geprüft hast.
Also, wir haben das vorher rechnerisch nachgewiesen.
Also, bevor es überhaupt losging, diese alte Adenauer-Version und diese alten
Eintragungen, die beruhten auf rechnerischen Nachweisen.
Das wird aber auch in der Automotive-Branche so gemacht, weil keiner mehr sein
Fahrzeug kaputt machen will, um das zu beweisen.
Und dann rechnet man einfach, ja, rechnet man einfach, passt,
passt nicht mit einem gewissen Sicherheitsfaktor.
Und wir haben dann, nachdem diese Ringo-Beschlagnahme war,
einfach um den, quasi, und dieses schlechte Gutachten aus Chemnitz kam,
haben wir gesagt, wir beweisen das nochmal ultimativ und haben den Bus in eine
Halle gestellt, unter Augen der DEKRA,
Unfallanalytikern und so weiter und haben sechs Tonnen aufs Dach geladen.
Also wir haben einfach so Wassertanks, IBCs heißen die.
International Balkon Container, Meter mal einen Meter mal einen Meter.
Der Bus wurde aufgebockt,
dass er nicht mehr auf dem Reifen steht, sondern halt auf so Werkstattböcken.
Dann wurden überall so Laserdistanzmessgeräte nach unten,
weil man will wissen, hier ist der Bus, ich lade jetzt ein Gewicht oben drauf,
Man will wissen, wird der Bus kleiner sozusagen und es gibt dann ne elastische,
ne ne dauerhafte, es gibt ne elastische und ne Beule oder Knackfrosch.
Und dann lädst du also 6 Tonnen drauf und misst, wie viel kleiner ist der Bus
geworden und unser Bus ist ein Millimeter kleiner geworden.
Und zwei Millimeter dicker, sozusagen. Und danach wird es dann wieder entladen.
Und dann war der Bus wieder ein Millimeter größer.
Und wieder zwei Millimeter dünner.
Und so wurde quasi nachgewiesen in einem Versuch, dass der Bus sechs Tonnen aushält ohne Problem.
Ja, aber jetzt muss er ja noch fahren und bremsen.
Ja, genau. Aber dafür, das ist halt quasi, erstens ist es ein Aufschlag,
weil wir haben gar keine sechs Tonnen auf dem Dach, sondern 1,5 plus minus 1,4.
Und das heißt, du hast dann einen Sicherheitsfaktor von drei oder vier,
was im Fahrzeugbau absolut unüblich ist. Im Fahrzeugbau ist Faktor zwei vielleicht üblich.
So, und dann für das Fahren und Bremsen haben wir einen Berge-Lkw kommen lassen,
und haben dann an der Dachlast, also an dem Dachträger, nach vorne mit so einem
Seilzug mit einer geeichten Waage von der DEKRA gezogen.
Und zwar 2G, also zweimal das eigene Gewicht nach vorne und ich glaube 1,5 oder
1,2 in jede andere Richtung. Damit ist quasi abgebildet, dass wenn du um eine
Kurve fährst, der Bus hält, also der Dach, es ist halt einfach nicht unsicher. Es hält einfach.
Es hält einfach, genau, es hält einfach.
Habt ihr jetzt schon überlegt, was ihr mit den weiteren Tonnen Dachlast,
die ihr jetzt habt, anstellen wollt?
Wir haben ja jetzt eine wunderbare Lage, weil wir jetzt quasi seit Neuestem,
ich weiß nicht, ob ich das überhaupt schon sagen darf, aber es ist jetzt so,
dass die Dekra in Berlin jetzt sich dann doch einen Ruck gegeben hat,
weil das immer so ein Ding war, wir hatten ein Fahrzeugpapier,
da steht halt drin mit Dachreling.
Aber da steht nicht drin, bis wie viel Kilo und so weiter. Und wir haben halt
einen Bus, der ist umgebaut zum Kunstwerk, so ein Stück weit.
Das steht nicht richtig drin, da steht einfach nur Bus drin.
Und dann haben die Polizei gesagt dann, hä, aber warum ist hier denn so ein
Gefechtsstand drin, warum ist hier ein Radar, warum ist hier irgendwie ein Wasserwerfer
angebaut, das ist ja alles nicht in den Dokumenten und das wurde jetzt, letzte Woche,
tatsächlich alles in die Dokumente eingetragen, also wir haben jetzt mittlerweile
den Bus, deswegen wir haben hier auch ein Stück weit Kraftfahrzeuggeschichte
geschrieben jetzt, weil wir haben jetzt einen Bus mit Papieren, das steht drin,
sonstiges Kfz zur Personenbeförderung, also kein Kraftfahrzeug,
sondern das ist jetzt ein sonstiges Kfz und es steht drin, mit Dachreling und
dann eine Prüfnummer mit einer Kilo ist eingetragen für einen Lastenträger und es steht drin,
mit Kunstausstellung für politische Bildung und Provokation.
Das ist eingetragen?
Da würde ich sagen, da können wir jetzt,
in die Serienfertigung gehen, doch endlich, oder?
Ja.
Und trotzdem, also diese Prüfnummer,
dieser Fahrzeugschein, Zulassungsbescheinigung Teil 2 oder was das ist?
Das ist wie bei Tunern jetzt.
Wie viele Seiten sind das jetzt?
Zwei. Also das ist jetzt wie so bei Tunern, also weil das unten nicht ausreicht,
weil da steht noch viel mehr drin.
Mit hinterer Ausstellung, Multimedial, sonst was, Zellentrakt und so weiter.
Und dann wird das so wie beim Tuner, wird dann an den Fahrzeugschein,
das steht unten so ganz kurz mit ganz viel Abkürzung. und dann steht so weiter
auf Seite 2 und dann hast du so für den Polizisten einen Fahrzeugschein.
Bumm, hier hast du deinen Fahrzeugschein.
Und dann kann er da durchlesen. Wir haben so Prüfplaketten bekommen von der
DEKRA mit einer Seriennummer und die haben wir extra so geklebt,
das ist total scheiße, weil die Polizei will jetzt gucken,
du stehst hier im Fahrzeugschein, die Nummer und dann haben wir die nicht außen,
sondern innen hingeklebt.
Genau, damit bei der Kontrolle ein bisschen was zu tun hat.
Ja, ist ja auch ein Sport mittlerweile. bei der Polizei, habe ich so den Eindruck
so sehr, wie die sich da reinhängen.
Ja.
Also insgesamt diese Bemühungen der Polizei Chemnitz, die finde ich schon so
ein bisschen unheimlich, ja, weil ich meine, spätestens nachdem sie das erste
Mal quasi verloren haben mit dem Ansinnen,
immer wieder zu Leuten zu sagen, der Bus ist jetzt da, beschlagnahmt den hier,
ich habe eine PowerPoint Präsentation gemacht, wie man den Bus beschlagnahmt
und so, und sich da mit den Leuten anzulegen,
dass Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich denke, dass da so die Steuergelder so sauber investiert sind.
Und ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob da nicht, das klingt so ein bisschen nach so
einer privaten Fede. Jetzt hast du diese Akten.
Ja.
Wo sind die denn eigentlich zum ersten Mal aufgetaucht?
Die Akten, also du kriegst ja Akteneinsicht. Bei uns ist das so,
man kriegt immer wieder. Und das muss ich dazu sagen, das ist auch das,
was die Polizisten nicht verstanden haben.
Und wo ich sagen muss, da muss ich mich bei unseren Fördermitgliedern eigentlich bedanken.
Also, weil wir ja sehr, sehr schlagkräftig mit Anwälten sind.
Sonst könnte ich das auch persönlich gar nicht durchhalten.
Also, der arme linke Aktivist auf einer Demonstration wird vom Polizisten angerempelt,
sagt, der hat mich angerempelt, sagen zehn Polizisten, nee, der hat uns angerempelt.
Dann kein Geld, rote Hilfe, Anwalt und so weiter.
Und ich würde das nicht durchhalten, auf fünf Ebenen oder sieben gleichzeitig
Prozesse zu führen, wenn nicht unsere ganzen Förderer, dass quasi die Sorgen,
die finanziellen Sorgen daraus
nehmen würden, dass einfach um sich dieses Rechtsthema gekümmert wird.
Weil sonst bist du ganz schnell, sodass du das nicht klarstellen kannst.
Aber du hast in Deutschland das Ding, es geht gegen dich ein Verfahren,
dann kannst du ja sofort, eigentlich kann der Anwalt hinschreiben,
hier wegen diesem Anhalten heute, allein schon beim Mängelschein,
kannst du sofort einen Brief hinschicken, Akteneinsicht.
So, jetzt ist es so, dass in dem Fall hatten wir das, in dem Fall der Beschlagnahme
in Döbeln, hatten wir das auch gemacht. Also wir sofort gesagt, bitte Akteneinsicht.
Wir haben die Akte aber nicht bekommen, wir haben beim Labo Berlin,
also bei der Zulagungsstelle, die hatten auch keine Akte.
Und da ging es um das Gutachten aus Chemnitz, was gesagt hat,
verkehrsunsicher, das Fahrzeug.
Und das hatte niemand. Die DEKRA Berlin konnte nicht reingucken, gesperrt im Computer.
Das Landesamt Bürger Ordnungsangelegenheiten, die zuständige Stelle in Berlin, hatten es nicht.
Wer es aber sehr wohl hatte, schon, war ein rechtsextremer YouTuber.
Warte mal, wann ist denn dieses Gutachten erstellt worden?
Nach dieser Beschlagnahme, die war ja September bei der Zerstin Döbeln,
und dann gab es eine Kurz, also es gab ein Kurzgutachten und ein Langgutachten.
Und das Gutachten wurde halt, also wahrscheinlich so in der Woche danach wurde
das quasi, wurde der Bus angeschaut von der DEKRA, dann durften wir ihn abholen
und nochmal eine Woche später wurde das Gutachten an die Polizei Chemnitz übermittelt,
laut heutiger Akteninformationen.
Und bis wir das dann hatten als Beschuldigte, oder Betroffene besser gesagt,
hat es noch mal mindestens zwei Wochen gedauert.
Wir haben einen sehr guten Kontakt zur Zulassungsstelle in Berlin.
Die waren auch so, wir haben hier nur diesen Fahrzeugschein,
wo zerstört draufsteht. Wir wissen gar nichts.
Wir haben nichts. Und dann gab es bei YouTube einen Eintrag,
wo der YouTuber Maurice Clark, AfD-Vorfeld, exakt aus dem Gutachten berichten konnte.
Und das gleiche hat sich dann nochmal wiederholt übrigens. Also das war das
Erste. Und dann gab es ein Langgutachten. Auch das hatte er wieder.
Wir haben dagegen Anzeige erstattet, wegen Verrat von Dienstgeheimnissen,
gegen die Chemnitzer Polizei und gegen die DEKRA vor Ort. Weil die DEKRA hat
gesagt, ne, bei uns nicht.
Wir so, super, danke, dann können es ja nur die gewesen sein.
Polizei, ja, wer denn jetzt nicht? Wenn es beide nicht waren, haben wir also,
Akteneinsicht, weil wir auch betroffen sind. Die wurde uns ewig nicht gewährt.
Vor zwei Wochen haben wir Akteneinsicht bekommen in dieser Geschichte.
Wer musste diese Akteneinsicht geben?
Na, unser Anwalt hat dann gesagt, wir sind hier betroffen. Ein Gutachten,
was uns betrifft, wurde quasi geleakt.
An wen wendet man sich da?
An die Staatsanwaltschaft.
In Chemnitz.
Genau, weil die müssten ja ermitteln. Wir haben ja gesagt, hey,
das Gutachten ist geleakt worden. Das ist Verrat von Dienstgeheimnissen.
Das ist ein hochsensibles Dokument. Hat ein rechter YouTuber. Warum?
Jetzt haben wir vor zwei Wochen Akteneinsicht bekommen. Habe ich hier irgendeine weiße Seite?
Machen wir mal schwarz. Das hier, so, ist die Akte.
Das sind die Ermittlungen, die die Polizei Chemnitz zu dieser Angelegenheit
erstellt hat. Also einfach gar nichts.
Also es wurde niemand befragt.
Und du musst wissen, gegen uns wurden...
Das ist das Gutachten.
Nein, nein.
Nein, nein. Das Gutachten nicht. Wir haben Anzeige erstattet wegen Verrat von
Dienstgeheimnissen gegen DEKRA und Polizei.
Und daraufhin haben sie nichts getan.
Nicht ermittelt.
Das ist auch immer so erstaunlich, die Polizei ist wahrscheinlich so überarbeitet,
den Adenauer zu suchen, dass sie gar nicht gegen sich selber ermitteln kann.
Und wir sind halt Künstler, deswegen haben wir dann, wir haben damals schon
anders reagiert und wir haben gesagt, okay, also als dieses Gutachten bei den
YouTubern waren, sind wir mit einem Anhänger nach Chemnitz vor das Polizeirevier gefahren,
Und haben den dort enthüllt und dort ist halt Ringo Schneider,
der Polizist, und Tino Chrupalla drauf zu sehen.
Und Tino Chrupalla hebt seine linke Hand zum Gruß und sagt, hey Ringo,
ist die Akte schon bei unseren YouTubern?
Und dann sagt der Ringo Schneider, klar Tino, Nazis haben bei mir immer Akteneinsicht.
Und rechts steht so ein Schild Chemnitz, Willkürhauptstadt Europas,
weil das ja die Kulturhauptstadt Europas war.
Und das Logo haben wir ganz leicht
verfremdet, das ist so ein angedeutetes Swastika quasi ist unter dem.
Genau. Und das Ganze ist unter dem so Ringo und Tino, genau,
Polizei Sachsen gibt Akte an Rechtsextremisten. Das war quasi unser Protest,
gegen die Geschichte.
Und seitdem ermittelt, also seitdem, weil das ist ja ein völlig anderer Fall,
ich bin hier der Verantwortliche, ich habe es zu verantworten sozusagen, aus Sicht von denen.
Und was ich hier mache ist Verwendung
von Zeichenterroristischen oder verfassungsfeindlichen Organisationen.
Das ist ein Paragraf im Recht, der sicherstellen soll, des Nazis keinen Hitlergruß zeigen.
Dass Nazis kein Hakenkreuz sich tätowieren. Darum geht's. Das ist der Grund für diesen Paragraf.
Und das ist jetzt jemand von einer, der sich seit 15, 20 Jahren gegen Rechtsextreme
engagiert, der davon betroffen ist, dass eine staatliche Stelle eine Akte an Rechtsextreme gibt.
Und der protestiert mit einem Kunstplakat in einer Kulturhauptstadt Europas.
Und daraufhin werde ich Seitdem werde ich mit allen Mitteln verfolgt.
Wirklich. Von der Polizei.
Einmal wegen Verwendung verfassungsfeindlicher Symbole, wobei ich da jetzt gar
nicht so sicher wäre bei diesem Kreuz da bei Europa.
Aber natürlich klar, der Ringo wird das jetzt nicht witzig gefunden haben.
Ich bin auch nicht angetreten, damit Ringo irgendwas witzig findet.
Das ist, ich wollte, ich versuche jetzt nur,
So jetzt machen die irgendwie so ein Ermittlungsverfahren, denkt man,
ja gut, komm, das ist ja, also das verläuft ja im Sande, ja.
Ihr habt aber noch so einen Instagram-Post zu dem, äh, zu diesem Poster gemacht.
Genau, wir haben, äh, so einen, wir haben halt quasi so ein Wetten-das-Geschichte gemacht.
Ähm, ich hab's aber nicht als, äh, als Ding, das wäre dann Tim mit Jingle.
Ja.
Das war so ein Video, da haben wir gesagt, wir machen das so Wetten-das-mäßig
und wir haben die Wette natürlich gewonnen.
Es wurde enthüllt und es wurde sofort beschlagen mit DNA-Abstrich und allem und so weiter.
Und daraus ergab sich dann, das ist ein völlig neuer Fall, eine weitere Verfahrensakte
mit mittlerweile 1000 Seiten, die daraus sich ergeben hat.
Tausend Seiten ja tausend Seiten wird die locker haben mittlerweile mit,
neuen Anfragen an Meta wegen wer hat das Video hochgeladen, die alle abgelehnt
wurden, Anfragen an Fluggesellschaften international weil der Dreh- und Angelpunkt
ist es wird behauptet, dass ich dieses Plakat enthüllt habe.
Problem ist Problem ist ich war halt neuntausend Kilometer weit weg nachweislich,
Was heißt hier nachweislich?
Nachweislich heißt, ich wurde da beschuldigt, unser Anwalt hat gesagt,
das können wir gleich ausräumen, hier ist das Flugticket.
Daraufhin wurde gesagt, hey, wurde dir toll kontaktiert, stimmt es,
dass der hier in Deutschland in den Flieger gegangen ist.
Er sagte, soll, ja, aber wir können nur sagen, hier, der ist nach Amsterdam
geflogen, aber wie er dann weitergeflogen ist, können wir nicht sagen.
Daraufhin wurde ein KLM eine Anfrage gestellt, ob ich auch in den Folgeflug eingecheckt bin.
Und dann hat KLM erst mal gesagt, ihr müsst ja schon erklären,
warum ihr das jetzt hier wissen wollt. Und dann wurde der Brief geschrieben,
ja, schwerster Verdacht hier, terroristisch verwendet. Das hört sich auch erst
mal gut an, Verwendung terroristischer.
Und daraufhin hat KLM dann gesagt, ja, klar.
Der ist da eingestiegen und hat auf Sitz 4E gesessen.
Ist also dann in anderes Land ganz weit weg. Die Chemnitzer, hm.
Und die Hypothese war dann, der ist doch mit einem Paddelboot wieder zurück.
Es gibt zwar keine Einreise, es gibt keinen erneuten Zoll, der ist nicht wieder eingereist.
So, haben die gesagt, aber es war jemand kräftig mit dem Bart. Das war er.
Also es gab einen Polizist, der da Zeuge war, der es gesehen hat, ne?
Und der wurde an dem Tag gefragt, was war das für einer? Ja,
so ein bisschen kräftig und mit Bart.
Und dann, fünf Monate später...
Wurde derselbe Polizist gefragt, ja, wegen diesem hier Typen,
kräftig mit Bart, wenn wir dir ein Foto zeigen würden, würdest du den vielleicht wiedererkennen?
Ja, würde ich. Beim ersten Mal dann noch gesagt, mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen.
Beim zweiten Mal gesagt, ja, würde ich wiedererkennen.
Und dann nochmal einen Monat später wurde dem Polizisten so ein Foto gezeigt,
guck mal hier, das ist Stefan Pelzer, das ist unser Verdächtiger, ist er das?
Und eigentlich in Deutschland, es gibt so eine Norm, du musst eigentlich acht
Fotos von irgendwelchen Leuten zeigen.
Dann sind die also damit zur Staatsanwaltschaft und haben gesagt,
Strafbefehl 50 Tagessätze, 2500 Euro und die Richterin Strafbefehl beantragt bei Gericht.
Alles in Chemnitz noch?
In Chemnitz, genau, bei Gericht. Die Richterin hat zurückgeschrieben Das macht aber keinen Sinn,
Das macht aber keinen Sinn Also die haben in dem Antrag geschrieben Also was
für ein Zweifel Soll ich daran verstehen?
Hat die Polizei Chemnitz ihre Richterin nicht unter Kontrolle oder was?
Daraufhin klingelt am Fusion Donnerstag um 6 Uhr bei mir die Polizei und beschlagnahmt meinen Computer.
Also du hältst gerade deinen Laptop hoch. Ja, den habe ich seit zwei Tagen wieder.
Lies mal vor, was auf dem Aufzuhörer steht.
Da steht Asservat. Und dann steht hier PT Chemnitz, KPI, Dezernat 5,
Geschäftszeichen, bla bla jatz. Und dann steht Asservatnummer.
Und da war irgendeine andere Asservatnummer drauf. Da ist mit Tippex dann wieder
eine andere Asservatnummer. Daran erkennt man, dass das richtig ist.
Das ist nur die Nummer 4, Alter.
Also 1, 2, 3, 4. Warum brauchst du Tipp-Hacks?
Scheiße, ich hab drei geschrieben. Jetzt haben wir zweimal, als er war drei. Naja.
Tipp-Hacks, ich wusste gar nicht, dass das noch gibt.
Und auch das war so. Da steht wirklich morgens, das ist eine total asoziale
Situation, weil da stehen Polizisten, in dem Fall sogar der Chemnitzer,
über den wir gleich noch reden werden, steht in deiner Wohnung morgens.
Die Polizei übernimmt die Kontrolle über alles.
Und das ist wirklich so, Du bist nicht mehr selbstbestimmt in deinem eigenen Zuhause.
Und es geht wirklich hier um das, was ihr hinter... Also es geht um dieses Plakat, um Kunst.
Und es geht vor allem um 50 Tagessätze, ah, 50 Euro. Das sind 2500 Euro.
Wegen 2500 Euro werden Meta-Neuen-Anfragen gestellt, international durch Suchungen,
nicht nur bei mir, bei noch weiteren Leuten, um festzustellen,
wie ist der wieder, wie hat er es geschafft, doch wieder in Chemnitz zu sein,
obwohl der eigentlich gar nicht da ist.
Man kann Verfahren auch einstellen, wenn man keinen Anhaltspunkt hat, so ne?
Ähm, und ähm, genau, und dann wurde, dann war die Berliner Polizei gesagt so,
ja, hm, also da kam der Anwalt natürlich und dann sagt, ja, kannst du es nicht
noch irgendwie ein bisschen mehr beweisen?
Die Berliner Polizisten waren nicht so begeistert von dem ganzen Chemnitzer
Ding, muss man wirklich schützend dazu sagen.
Und dann so, ja, ich könnte ein paar Urlaubsfotos zeigen, habe ich gesagt.
Und dann so, ja, okay. Aber dann wurde ausgemacht, das Handy darf nicht beschlagnet,
es wird entsperrt, aber ich bin so einen Meter weg und mache so.
Guck mal, hier kommt meine Freundin. Guck mal da.
Dann so, ja, außerdem habe ich die ganze Zeit mit Karte bezahlt.
Wir sagen mal, Bank, guck mal hier, noch mal ein Eis, noch mal ein Hotel.
Und dann der Bettener Polizist so zu dem Kämlitzer. Also mir würde das reichen.
Und dann war kurz so, okay, darf Computer und Handy behalten.
Und man muss dazu sagen, dass ich hier bei der Fusion, weil ich mich ja nicht
nur mit dem Bus, sondern ich beschäftige mich generell mit Bussen,
auch hier auf der Fusion. Und ich war,
gegenüber dem Amt eingetragen als quasi für Schutzräume im Katastrophenfall.
Und ich habe gesagt, ey Leute, das ist auch halt mein Computer.
Ich bin hier so im Katastrophenschutzkonzept benannt.
Und da sind 70.000 Leute auf einer Veranstaltungsfläche. Und wenn hier Schutzräume,
dann kann ich nicht richtig arbeiten ohne meinen Computer.
Und dann die Berliner Polizisten auch wieder so ein bisschen unruhig.
Was machen wir hier gerade?
Und am Schluss hat der Chemnitzer Polizist gesagt, nee, den Computer nehmen wir mit.
Und das Argument, warum, war, sonst haben wir doch gar nichts hier.
Und am selben Abend hat es hier einen Waldbrand gegeben auf dem Festivalgelände.
Ne, außerhalb des Festivals.
Da haben wir sehr viel Wert drauf gelegt. Evakuierung und so.
Evakuierung und alles. Und ich sag dir, an dem Abend war denen nicht gut zumute,
als sie das auf tagesschau.de gelesen haben, dass sie hier dem,
der die Schutzräume stellt, seinen Computer morgens weggenommen haben.
Wegen 50 Tagessätzen.
Und genau. Und jetzt ist dann so, was ist der Effekt? Ich hab ihn ja seit zwei,
drei, vier Tagen wieder.
Und der steht auch in der Akte, ja, mit den hier, das haben wir den versucht
zu erklären, Leute, das ist ein M4 verschlüsseltes MacBook, ihr könnt da nichts
mit anfangen, wenn wir euch das Passwort nicht sagen.
Ja, egal, nehmen wir mit, an der Akte steht genau das drin, kann mit den hier
zur Verfügung stehenden Mitteln nichts gemacht werden.
Also, Leute, guter Computer, Verschlüsselung und gutes Passwort.
Dann beißt sich die...
Hey, Ringo!
Hey Ringo.
So, das ist die Schiene, das habe ich wieder. Aber zu Problemen.
Ich will erstmal nochmal wirklich zusammenfassen, wie völlig irrsinnig das ist,
dass jemand einen Beweis liefert,
nicht im Land gewesen zu sein und dann kriegst du eine Hausdurchsuchung mit
Beschlagnahme deines Rechners, weil sie irgendwie beweisen wollen,
wie du doch da gewesen bist. Also,
das... Ich... Stefan und ich haben gestritten,
über die Ankündigung dieser Veranstaltung im Attention-Programm.
Wo gesagt wird, dass wir die Polizei lächerlich machen.
Und ich bin echt der feste Überzeugung, dass die Polizei sich doch hier lächerlich macht.
Also es sind himmelschreiende Rechtsmissbräuche und Willkürhandlungen,
die wir hier von der Polizei Chemnitz sehen.
Ich bin da wirklich erschüttert. Ich finde das lustig, hier drüber zu lachen
und so. Und ich finde das auch wichtig, auch dieses Zeichen zu setzen,
dass man sich davon nicht unterkriegen lässt. Da könnt ihr mal kurz applaudieren
für Stefan und alle SupporterInnen.
Aber das ist...
Wahnsinn. Was erlaube Chemnitz?
Also was haben...
Was sagt eigentlich Thomas Gottschalk dazu?
Was treibt... Hast du mal... Hast du wahrscheinlich...
Was geht denn da ab? Das ist ja alles schon auf einem Level,
wo man jetzt nicht sagt, das ist
jetzt pure Inkompetenz und die sind jetzt irrlichternd und die haben alle,
ihre Ausbildung irgendwie vergessen und sind nicht in der Lage, also das ist ja...
Es ist Rechtsmissbrauch, also es ist quasi eine Polizei und da kann,
das ist jetzt eine dunkle Vision, die ich da leider für euch hab,
weil es ist so, da könnt, wenn ihr das als Geschmack mal, wie Leute quasi sagen,
hey, wir haben hier so einen persönlichen Fight, weil sich einer nicht unterkriegen lässt.
Also, da ist einer, der gibt mir einfach konstant, statt zu sagen,
das ist ja mein negatives Nachtatverhalten, was mir so zur Last gelegt wird.
Das negative Nachtatverhalten, da musst du echt mal dran arbeiten.
Stefan. Deswegen würde mein Bußgeld erhöht um 170 Euro, weil ich halt nach dieser
Beschlagnahmung, das steht auch in meinem Bußgeldbescheid,
steht drin, wegen meinem negativen Nachtatverhalten würde das angemessen von
250 auf 390 Euro erhöht, weil ich eine Pappfigur mit dem Polizisten auf Veranstaltungen
vorzeige, die Polizeiarbeit lächerlich mache und so weiter und so fort.
Aber die sind richtig angepisst davon, dass einer sich nicht unterkriegen lässt,
und nutzen dann alle Mittel des Staates, um so eine Geschichte, ihr habt es ja gesehen.
Also zeigt doch mal, beim CSD in Bautzen sind Nazis, die zeigen Hitlergruß.
In Spiegel TV dokumentiert. Was meint ihr, was für Anstrengungen da unternommen wurden?
Meint ihr, da hat es Hausdurchsuchungen gegeben, um richtige Strafverfolgung?
Und es geht hier wirklich darum, den verfolgen wir jetzt selektiv,
weil der widerspricht uns und macht uns lächerlich.
Der verarscht uns eigentlich. ich.
Und dort sind Polizisten, die nutzen die gesamte Macht des Staates,
die ihnen eigentlich zur Verfügung steht, um Terroristen zu jagen oder in dem Fall Tuner.
Aber der Polizei gegeben wurde vom Volk und von unseren demokratischen Institutionen,
die haben ja bestimmte Mächte bekommen und mit denen müssen sie vorsichtig umgehen,
das mildeste Mittel, Interessen abwägen,
das Ganze zum guten Ende führen, Strafen Straftaten verfolgen.
Und stattdessen sind die so blind, wütend und nutzen ihr gesamtes Werkzeug,
Durchsuchungsbeschlüsse über Bundesländer, Auskunftsersuchen an amerikanische Konzerne, KLM,
Flugdatenauskunft, Beschlagnahmung von Laptop und so weiter.
Und sammeln auch so, dass alle mich möglichst anzeigen. Die laufen rum und sagen,
alle müssen den anzeigen.
Zum Beispiel Thomas Gottschalk. Die haben eine E-Mail an Thomas Gottschalk.
Man schreibt nicht einfach eine E-Mail an Thomas Gottschalk.
Also, ja. Wir gucken jetzt alle hier Stirnrunzeln her.
Aber dieses Video war ja Thomas Gottschalk. Wir
haben also ein Thomas Gottschalk-Wetten-das-Video gemacht. Kunst! Kunst!
Und der Polizist, der später dann in meiner Wohnung stand...
Wie hieß der nochmal?
Der hieß Manuel Müller.
Manuel Müller.
Genau. Und wir dürfen das ja hier überhaupt gar nicht zeigen.
Aber der hat eine E-Mail an den Herrn Gottschalk geschrieben.
Genau, und hat gesagt, ich würde ihn dort in der öffentlichen Meinung herabwürdigen
mit diesem Video. Und es ist rechtlich gesehen so.
Erstens Staatsanwalt. Also wenn es eine Straftat gab, dann darf ein Staatsanwalt,
falls die Person, die betroffen ist, das nicht weiß, darf ein Staatsanwalt die informieren.
Also euch wurde eine Straftat angetan.
Ihr wisst es aber gar nicht. Aber die Polizei hat es aber ermittelt und der Staatsanwalt weiß es.
Dann darf der Staatsanwalt euch informieren. hey Tim, gegen dich gibt es hier
eine Straftat, dass du weißt, du kannst das anzeigen.
So, aber erstens, er ist kein Staatsanwalt, sondern ein Polizist.
Also, schau mal, nicht seine Baustelle.
Zweitens schreibt er, ich bitte Sie daher, umgehend den beiliegenden Strafantrag
auszufüllen und mir wieder per E-Mail zukommen zu lassen.
An Thomas Gottschalk. Ja, aber das Schlimme ist, Thomas Gottschalk reagiert nicht.
Und dann schreibt er eine zweite E-Mail.
Sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, ich bitte dringend um Bearbeitung meines polizeilichen Ersuchens.
Dringend fett unterstrichen und kursiv. Alle Knöpfe, die das E-Mail-Programm hat.
Vielen Dank.
Priorität hoch. Meines polizeilichen Ersuchens.
Lies mal unten. Was ist das Motto der Polizei Chemnitz?
Professionalität, Toleranz, Verantwortung.
Aber das ist ja auch so ein schönes Spiel mit den Vokabeln. Dringend um Bearbeitung
meines polizeilichen Ersuchens. Alter, du bellst, dass Thomas Gottschalk das
Zentrum für politische Schönheit anzeigt.
Das ist kein polizeiliches Ersuchen, was der bearbeiten muss.
Ich kann euch beruhigen, Thomas Gottschalk hat auch darauf nicht geantwortet.
Aber da sieht man auch, das ist nicht normale Polizeiarbeit,
sondern das ist schwarz auf weiß,
Mittel, die überhaupt nicht zulässig sind in einem Strafverband.
Das sagt übrigens auch, könnt ihr euch angucken, tagesschau.de hat jetzt gerade
berichtet, die sind auch irgendwie an diese Akte gekommen, ich habe keine Ahnung wie.
Von dem YouTuber.
Genau, wahrscheinlich vom YouTuber, genau. Und die haben auch dazu die Staatsanwaltschaft angefragt.
Was sagen sie dazu, wenn so ein Polizist an Thomas Gottschalk da eine E-Mail
schreibt und sagt, er soll jetzt hier dringend den Strafbefehl ausschönen,
da haben die darauf geantwortet, das kann ja gar nicht sein,
das wäre ja gar nicht zulässig.
Ja, so geht's Sächsisch.
Sag mal, diese, ich meine, hast du den Eindruck, dass all diese ganze Aktivität
allein aus dem Polizeiapparat herauskommt, weil ich meine, die unterstehen ja auch nochmal Behörden.
Da ist ja sozusagen noch ein politischer Überbau, der letztlich ja auch die
Aufgabe hat, die Arbeit der Polizei zu kontrollieren, beziehungsweise deren
Maßnahmen, Methodik etc.
In irgendeiner Form auch eine Linie zu geben.
Ja, man muss jetzt sagen, da gibt es eigentlich das Parlament.
Es gibt auch ein Innenministerium. Ja, Innenminister, das ist der Schuster in Sachsen.
Sehr polizeifreundlich, also sehr unkritisch. Und dann gibt es den Landtag,
der da Kontrolle ausübt. Es gibt natürlich Ausschüsse und so weiter.
Und man muss dazu sagen, jetzt gerade sieht die Polizei Sachsen nicht gut aus in der Angelegenheit.
Wirklich? Ja, also jetzt gerade...
Mit der nächsten Beschlagnahme wird das alles in Ordnung kommen.
Ja, weil der Fall ist jetzt öffentlich. Aber auch das ist wieder nur,
weil wir das halt gegen die durchziehen gerade.
Bisher war immer so, ne die Polizei ist unabhängig, die dürfen das so machen
und so weiter und das lag ja alles verschlossen, also diese Akten sind bei uns
erst vor drei Wochen eingegangen auch, dass man so krass sehen kann was die eigentlich da treiben,
und jetzt gerade mit der Berichterstattung der aktuellen Woche glaube ich,
dass die Luft gerade relativ, also die Stimmung ist schlecht glaube ich,
bei der Polizei, vor allem auch hatten wir in anderen Fällen in ganz anderen
Angelegenheiten über Netzwerke und auch Journalisten Kontakt zu,
Empfängern dieser Handlungsanleitung, weil wir müssen ja überprüfen,
ob Carsten Kempf seinen Pflichten nachkommt und das widerruft alles und so weiter.
Und dort wurde, in einem anderen Bundesland, wurde von einem Polizeipräsidenten,
bei der AG Einsatz, das ist das, wo diese Handlungsanweisung hinging,
die illegale, nachgefragt, ob sie die auch bekommen haben. Hat der AG Einsatz
der Leiter da gesagt, ja, haben wir.
Dann wurde gefragt, haben wir die weitergeleitet, Um zu klären,
müssen wir jetzt auch zurückrufen. Und dann war die Antwort,
Nee, haben wir nicht. Die Polizeidirektion Chemnitz nimmt in Sachen Adenauer
keiner mehr für voll hier.
Also weil die selber so prüfen müssen.
Also die sehen nicht gut aus gerade, das muss man sagen.
Die sind, wir sagen, das ist ein bisschen sturmreif geschossen auch mit den
ganzen Fristen jetzt und so weiter.
Aber es ist trotzdem, das ist trotzdem, das ist das Ende, oder vielleicht das
Ende, vielleicht auch nicht, einer zermürbenden Auseinandersetzung für uns.
Weil wir haben da keinen Bock drauf. Das ist das Ding. Die haben da Bock drauf
und die sitzen da mit ihrem, die werden da bezahlt, haben ihr Beamten-Ding und schreiben da.
Derselbe Manuel Müller, oder wie er heißt, der Polizeibeamte,
der in meiner Wohnung stand und meinen Computer mitgenommen hat,
weil sonst haben wir ja sonst nichts. Sonst haben wir ja gar nichts hier.
Die haben ja auch nix.
Die haben ja nix. Wir hatten ja nix. Wir hatten ja nix.
Der selber hat so eingesammelt, Strafanzeigen gegen mich, von allen möglichen
seiner Kollegen, weil wir ein YouTube-Video produziert haben, wo die drauf waren.
Und hat dann von allen möglichen Leuten, die da dabei waren in der Situation,
einfach so, ich stelle Strafantrag wegen allen möglichen Dingen,
die da vorkommen können.
Und dann leitet er die weiter mit Smiley dran. Heute kommen noch fünf Smiley.
Also es ist ein zermürbender Kampf und jetzt stehen wir quasi so am Ende dieser Auseinandersetzung.
Hast du auch von anderen beteiligten Behörden da irgendwie Feedback bekommen,
die müssen sich doch auch alle irgendwie völlig bekloppt vorkommen.
Beim Labo in Berlin, da bei der Zulassungsbehörde, die kriegen doch irgendwie
alle naselange immer wieder dieselbe Frage gestellt.
Also ich darf nicht aus meinen internen Gesprächen mit dem Labo,
aber die Quintessenz ist die Nerven.
Ja.
Also die nerven auch das Labo, das nervt das Labo und die sehen das auch so,
die sehen halt so, hey, ihr seid nicht zuständig. Also ihr seid nicht zuständig,
wir sind zuständig. Das heißt, wir prüfen.
Und wir haben jetzt alles geprüft.
Und es ist fertig geprüft auch. Es ist jetzt fertig geprüft.
Und das ist die Position des Labo. Wir haben das so formuliert,
als wir es nochmal geprüft haben. Haben wir eine gemeinsame Formulierung gefunden.
Und die heißt, damit setzen wir einen Schlussstrich unter die zulassungsrechtlichen
Fragen rund um diesen Bus. Und dann wurde bestätigt, genau so machen wir das.
Und seitdem ist klar, das ist fertig geprüft.
Und gehst du jetzt davon aus, dass du es nicht mehr beschlagen haben wirst?
Nein.
Doch, ich gehe eigentlich davon aus, weil gerade im Moment erstens bin ich Rechtsstaatverliebt
sozusagen. Ich glaube an das Gute im Rechtsstaat.
Und es ist tatsächlich so, dass im Moment es so ist, also auch wegen der medialen
Berichterstattung, aber jetzt gerade hat glaube ich keine Polizei mehr richtig Bock auf das Ding.
Das merke ich daran, dass wir in Sachsen-Anhalt angehalten werden von der Polizei.
Und die Scheibe runter und dann kommt, keine Sorge, wir wollen euch nicht kontrollieren.
Wir bringen euch nur zum Einsatzort.
Oh Mann, hast du so weich gespürt. Genau, aber das ist ein extremst langer Weg gewesen dahin.
Auf jeden Fall.
Okay.
Dieser lange Weg hat ja Kosten auf beiden Seiten. Der hat auf eurer Seite Kosten.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass nicht alle Anwaltskanzleien, die beschäftigt werden, jeden Cent abrechnen.
Nee, viele laufen pro bono, viele laufen zu sehr günstigen Tarifen.
Es ist immer sehr wichtig, dass bei uns echt große Kanzleien,
am besten steht Kanzlei des Jahres irgendwo rechts oder sowas,
weil das einfach schon den Eindruck gut macht.
Aber es verursacht Kosten. Aber auf der Staatsseite, wir haben jetzt geschätzt,
dass die Staatsseite bei ungefähr 700.000 Euro ist und wir sind trotzdem auch bei 100.000.
Aber das Interessante ist auch für den Staat, das ist nämlich auch so eine Mäßigung
dann für den Staat, dass wir ja dreimal irgendwelche Beschlagnahmen oder Gerichtsverfahren hatten.
Und dann ist es ganz lustig, weil
ihr kriegt dann so einen, ich bin ja der Beschuldigte, ich bin der Halter.
Und dann ist das Fahrzeug angeblich verkehrsunsicher. Dann kriegst du einen
Bußgeldbescheid und da steht dann so drin, sie erlaubten, dass ein Fahrzeug
in Betrieb genommen wurde, das nicht sicher war.
Bußgeld 250 Euro, ein Punkt in Flensburg,
negatives Nachtatverhalten nochmal 100 oder 150 und dann kommt so,
Verfahrensnebenkosten 12.876 Euro. Ja, genau.
Weil abschleppen, Begutachtung, pipapo und das ist interessant,
weil das landet bei mir, aber wir greifen das ja an und das ist jetzt in Brandenburg
einmal passiert, wer hat es bezahlt?
Der Brandenburger Steuerzahler am Ende in Berlin einmal passiert, wer hat es bezahlt?
Der Berliner Steuerzahler in Berliner Steuerzahler in, genau und jetzt in Sachsen
gibt es den ultimativen Showdown zum Thema 18.11.
Save the Date weil wir es jetzt das erste Mal vor Gericht schaffen damit,
also weil vorher wurde das immer eingestellt einfach dann zu Lasten der Staatskasse,
weil die keinen Bock drauf hatten.
In Brandenburg wollte es auch schon durchziehen. Die haben so gesagt,
hey, wir setzen den Termin an, eine Stunde.
Und wir so, wie eine Stunde? Wir haben 15 Zeugen.
Und dann so, ja, okay, dann gucken wir mal, dann vielleicht schon um neun.
Und dann, nächster Tag rufen da zehn Journalisten an und wollen ihre Presseplätze schon mal abklären.
Und dann hörst du, dann nimmst du, was kommt, eingestellt.
Und keiner Bock drauf. Und jetzt in ... Genau.
In Döbeln, 18. November, wer Bock hat, der Adenauer kommt auch.
Am 18. November ist in Döbeln die Verhandlung um diese ganze Beschlagnahme Döbeln,
die ja rechtswidrig war und so weiter.
Oh, geil.
Und es ist eine Publikumsgeschichte, deswegen ich lade auch alle Hörer ein,
checkt die Seite, kommt alle. Wir machen die Messe alle voll weit.
Dort schaffen wir es scheinbar, scheinbar tatsächlich vor Gericht.
Und wir laden unsere 10, 12 Zeugen, aber zusätzlich sind auch die Zeugen der
Gegenseite also geladen, die DEKRA-Prüfer aus Chemnitz und Ringo, genau.
An die habe ich wichtige Fragen. Und das Coole ist,
ich habe mir das gerade erst vom Anwalt erklären lassen, zuerst darf die Richterin
den Zeugen oder die Zeugin befragen, dann Staatsanwalt, falls überhaupt vor
Ort, dann Verteidigungsanwalt und dann ich.
So geil! Also, ich darf Ringo Schneider ins Kreuzverhör nehmen.
Ja, ist doch heute schon weiter.
Es wird in die Geschichte eingehen als das aufwendigste Ordnungswidrigkeitenverfahren.
Es geht um 250 Euro und einen Punkt.
Wie viel Platz ist denn da?
Weiß ich nicht, da müssen die sich drum kümmern. Aber wir machen sonst eine Leinwand davor.
Mit Livestream. Genau, mit Livestream. Fanmeile.
Darf man sowas streamen?
Das müssen wir jetzt alles klären, aber ich kann empfehlen, 18.
November, save the date.
Livestream wäre geil.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Das kommentieren wir dann noch direkt vorne auf dem Platz.
Im Gerichtssaal sitzen wir einfach und kommentieren live.
Wie so ein Fußballspiel.
Wir können auch mal anfragen, ob wir das nicht auf der Palafel machen können.
Wie viele Verhandlungstage sind angesetzt?
Ja, sie war nämlich so, das war genau das Gleiche. Die Richterin meinte 13 Uhr,
und dann so, 13 Uhr und um 14 Uhr machst du Färben, das kann ja nicht sein.
Und dann hat der Anwalt gesagt, ich glaube nicht, dass wir mit einem Verhandlungstag
hinkommen in der Angelegenheit.
Und jetzt ist es, sie hat gesagt, hm, okay, sie will es aber schon in einem durchschaffen.
Aber jetzt wird es irgendwie morgens angesetzt und wir sind jetzt in Verhandlungen,
aber es wird wirklich der ultimative Showdown der Gutachter und Mathematikprofessorinnen,
UnfallanalytikerInnen.
Das ist wirklich das ultimative Verkehrsordnungswidrigkeitenverfahren.
Glaubst du eigentlich, dass diese Hausdurchsuchung und Beschlagnahme am Fusion
Donnerstag, das ist ja...
Das ist schon ein äußerst ungünstiger Tag.
Nein.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass das irgendwas mit was hat. Die gucken nicht,
was hat der zu tun. Die haben nicht so einen Background-Check und sagen,
hey, weil das war wirklich so 6 Uhr.
Und wir waren halt tatsächlich seit 5 Uhr wach, weil wir haben da zu tun an
dem Tag. Und ich war auf dem Klo, als die reinkamen gerade so.
Aber nein, weil der Durchsuchungsbeschluss war schon 4 Wochen alt.
Das ist einfach so, deutsche Behörden malen langsam und irgendwann passt dann.
Weil die Wahrscheinlichkeit eigentlich auch relativ gering ist,
dass sie, also ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass man dich am Future Donnerstag noch zu Hause antrifft.
20 Minuten später wäre ich weg gewesen, aber das wäre schlimm gewesen,
weil die wären ja trotzdem gekommen.
Und genau, also das ist, ja, es war wie es war, es war sehr unangenehm und aber es war wie es war.
Geiles auch, aber da muss ich noch was dazu sagen. Hier ist ja ein Computer,
das ist mein Zweitcomputer und das ist der Computer, der beschlagnahmt wurde.
Aber auf dem Computer hier steht vor oben, steht hier Tatwaffe drauf.
Glaube ich, oder? Hier steht ja gut Tatwaffe.
Zentrumsaufklebersatz.
Haben die nicht mitgenommen.
Tatwaffe.
Komisch.
Oh Mann.
Krasse Durchsuchung. Richtig gut dabei. Die können das alles richtig gut da in Camp.
Also ihr könnt unter Hey Ringo das Computerspiel spielen, wo ihr die Akten möglichst
schnell zu den Neonazis bringen müsst. Vor Justitia flüchten.
Den Adenauer jagen. Die Unterlassungserklärung abgeben.
Mit der Akte chatten.
Man kann ja so Mitte, es gibt eine Akten-KI, man kann, du kannst sagen,
und dann kriegst du gerade eine Fragestellung, dann kommt erst immer Ringos
Position und dann kommt unsere Position.
Also da kommt die Faktencheck, das ist der Kern der Website.
Ich kann nur sagen, wie viel Spaß es macht, mit diesem Fahrzeug zu fahren.
Das war schon bei unserer ersten Folge, die Fahrt durch Berlin.
An jeder Ampel laufen Leute vorbei und winken.
Zuletzt sind wir am 1. Mai noch ein bisschen damit gefahren.
Das war auch ein... Da wurde die nachher noch kontrolliert, ne?
Da waren wir zum Glück gerade...
Ja, da wurde man kontrolliert. Das war dann... Das war so...
Da hat sich auch so eine Polizei halt selbstständig gemacht.
Also da war eigentlich ein super Tag gehabt.
Weil am 1. Mai wieder Nicht-Berliner in Berlin waren.
Nee, das waren Berliner, aber das waren irgendwelche, die waren aggro.
Da habe ich auch wieder eine Anzeige kassiert.
Negatives Nachtartverhalten.
Nee, ich habe gesagt, ihr benehmt euch hier wie besoffene Union-Hooligans.
Was soll das denn heißen?
Zwei Bier, sagt der Tim dann.
Das war bestimmt Herr Tarner.
Ja, da sind die uns auf einmal hinterhergefahren. Es war ein toller Tag.
Es war übrigens echt lustig, weil wir waren am 1. Mai in Berlin in Grunewald. Bei Mike Runi.
Und da zwei Key Takeaways davon, das erste ist,
man fährt so an irgendwie, findet einen richtigen Weg, auf einmal klingelt das
Telefon, weil die irgendwo meine Nummer von der vorherigen Versammlung haben und sagen,
wo sind sie denn, wo sind sie denn, ja wir kommen gerade an,
aber wir kennen uns auch nicht aus in Grunewald und dann so,
hast du jemanden am Telefon, in dem Moment wirst du von der Polizei angehalten
und es sind Chemnitzer Polizisten.
Die aber sagen, die sind uns zugeordnet. Das war so der Polizeichef am Telefon.
Das ist ein Witz hier gerade, oder? Mit die Chemnitzer Polizeihilfecht zu stehen.
Aber die waren in Ordnung. Aber das Lustige ist, dann habe ich gesagt,
hier sind Polizisten, ja dann sagen Sie denen doch mal, was jetzt so sein soll.
Dann habe ich auf laut gemacht, ich habe euren Chef dran.
Und dann hat der das so durch mein Telefon. Und danach habe ich gedacht,
ich hätte auch jemanden im Bus hinten drin sitzen haben können.
Die hätten diese Hörigkeitsfunktion der Polizisten. Ja, hier,
PAK 709. Ihr müsst dann jetzt, ihr fahrt die jetzt rechts, dann zweimal links.
Und dann steht ihr auf der A100, da stellt ihr sie quer.
Also genau, man hätte das locker geschafft, dass die Polizei einen mitten auf
die Autobahn eskortiert und da quer hinstellt, wenn man nur gewollt hätte.
Und dann hatten wir einen tollen Tag im Grunewald, Musik gemacht,
alles super und alles war total deeskalativ, alles ist gut gelaufen.
Gab es sogar eine FDP-Gegendemo gegen uns.
Dann hast du einen geilen Tag, wenn die FDP gegen dich demonstriert.
Und dann sind wir zurück und auf unser eigenes, da wurde ein Bus abstellt und
irgendwie mittendrin hat sich so eine Polizeihundschaft ohne Rücksprache,
mit der Polizeiführung einfach an uns rangehangen, dann haben wir geguckt,
okay, lassen wir die mal, aber es ist ein Privatgelände und dann sind die uns
bis aufs Privatgelände hinterhergefahren,
Dann hab ich ausgestiegen und hab gesagt, so Jungs, jetzt reicht's,
das ist ein Privatgelände, da ist ein Schild dran, so, unbefugten ist der Zutritt
verboten und das seid ihr.
Weil das ist so, das ist keine öffentliche Verkehrsweg und dann haben die,
wir gehen hier gar nicht weg, total aggressiv, das war kurz vorm Eskalieren,
die haben uns da echt blöd angemacht.
Und dann standen die so in der Ecke und ich so, ey, ihr müsst abhauen,
ihr müsst weg und dann so wir gehen die gar nicht, wir schreiben die Anzeige
gegen mich und da hat ich zum Glück einen Parlamentarier am Telefon
hab ich denen gesagt, ihr benehmt euch hier wie besoffene Unionhooligans zack,
jetzt hab ich sie auch noch beleidigt und so weiter und dann hat der parlamentarische
Betreuer die Polizeiführung angerufen, die wussten nichts davon, was machen die?
War so die Frage und dann haben die versucht, die über Funk zu erreichen,
um wegzudämmen, die abhauen von dem Geräte. Die Waren aber irgendwie nicht mehr zu kriegen.
Und dann haben die Zivilpolizisten geschickt, um denen zu sagen, verpisst euch.
Es kamen dann so die Polizisten an und ich würde so, ja, wir sind auch nur hergeschickt
worden, weil irgendwie eine Polizeihundertschaft durchgedreht ist, haben die so gesagt.
Die waren auch cool, das waren so zwei, die waren migrantisch und sowas waren,
das waren dann zwei gute Polizisten. Und dann sind die so geschnaufen,
mit ihren Autos abgedampft.
Genau. Ja.
Das Familienfest.
Ja, genau. Wo kann man denn denn, also ihr seid jetzt viel unterwegs in Sachsen-Anhalt
und Magdeburg-Vorpommern.
Ja, wir machen lustige Sachen, wir finden auch immer neue Sachen.
Jetzt ist ja das Podcast, der wird dann anders veröffentlicht, aber morgen ist in,
Sachsen-Anhalt in Magdeburg Familienfest zum Wahlkampfabschluss mit Ulrich Siegmund
und Tino Chrupalla und vielen mehr.
Und wir haben uns gedacht, wir machen an genau demselben Ort,
zu genau derselben Zeit...
Ein Antifa-Million-Fest.
Zum Wahlkampfabschluss mit Ulrich Siegmund, Tino Chrupalla und dem Adenauer SRP Plus.
Am 4. September, Einlass, 12 Uhr.
Beginn 14 Uhr. Also genau das gleiche Programm. Genau, das ist mein Neues.
Ich liebe das Antifa-Million-Fest.
Ansonsten, genau, wir sind jetzt gerade noch in Magdeburg. wahrscheinlich Veröffentlichung
ist nach der Wahlkatastrophe von.
Sonntag wahrscheinlich ne,
genau das heißt aber es lohnt sich dann immer noch weiter zu kämpfen man kann
nicht in die Zukunft in die Vergangenheit kann man gucken in die Zukunft nicht so richtig,
und dann die nächsten zwei Wochen ist dann in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern geht es
nochmal ums Ganze es geht insgesamt ums Ganze, es geht ja darum,
wenn man so ein bisschen progressive Politik oder linke Politik gemacht hat,
wundert man sich auf einmal,
dass man so hingeht und sagt, wir müssen hier irgendwie um unsere Gesellschaft,
wir müssen um unseren Staat kämpfen. Sozusagen.
Ist eine komische Situation, aber es geht hier tatsächlich ums Ganze,
denn im Fall von Sachsen-Anhalt, es geht ja eigentlich darum,
dass solche Polizeiarbeit, wie sie gegen uns durchgeführt wird,
wenn ein Bundesland an der AfD-Regierung verfällt, dann steht,
diese ganzen Behörden sind alle weisungsgebunden.
Das heißt, dann steht der AfD auf einmal die gesamte Power des Staates zur Verfügung.
Und dann kann man nur hoffen, dass sich andere Bundesländer sagen,
wir machen da nicht mit, denn die können noch selbst prüfen.
Aber an und für sich, wenn in Sachsen-Anhalt irgendjemand sagt,
hey, gegen den Linus haben wir so und so einen Verdachtsmoment,
scheißegal, oder gegen den Tim, weil er besoffen wieder Union gehooligant hat.
Und dann ordnet in Sachsen-Anhalt ein Gericht irgendwas gegen irgendjemanden
von euch, gegen irgendjemanden von uns an.
Dann ist eigentlich Amtshilfe Berlin dafür zuständig, das dann umzusetzen.
Dann kommen die, nehmen den Computer weg und der geht dann nach Sachsen-Anhalt.
Dann kann auf einmal Sachsen-Anhalt Anfragen an Meta, also diese Behörden dort,
die fallen dann auf einmal an die Rechtsextremisten.
Und das ist wirklich in dieser ganzen Geschichte, die wir jetzt schon haben
mit der AfD und der Geschichte mit rechter Gewalt und der Geschichte mit Nazi-Schläger,
Baseball-Schläger-Leuten, das ist eine völlig andere Qualität,
wenn auf einmal die staatlichen Mittel an die Nazis fallen.
Und das ist was, man kann hoffen, dass es nicht so kommt und es lohnt sich dagegen
zu kämpfen. Auf jeden Fall.
Und? Haben wir nur ein bisschen überzogen.
Wir haben nur ein bisschen überzogen. Das war Lockbuch Netzpolitik.
Bisschen überzogen ist. Wette gewonnen, oder?
Ja, das Wette gewonnen.
Lockbuch Netzpolitik.
Oh nein, das hast du schon abmoderiert. Danke, Attention.
Was, ey? Die Wette gewonnen.
Weil ich will noch ganz auf den Sitz sagen, wir machen das hier live auf der
Tim, das hört ihr im Hintergrund.
Man kann nur sagen, danke an alle, die das möglich machen. Danke an die Leute,
die die Technik machen. Danke an den Kulturkosmos. Danke an die Gäste.
Und ich sag dazu auch noch, danke an die beiden Hosts, danke an Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Und danke an Stefan vom Zentrum und alle, die das möglich machen,
was wir hier als Unterhaltungsprogramm bieten, weil das ist,
glaube ich, auch Knochenjob, aber ist ein geiler. Vielen Dank für alles, was ihr tut.
Applaus.